[Music]
[Laughter]
see i remembered
i told him i was like i was just looking
for a [ __ ] one that i made and i was
just kind of like well i was looking for
like some uh stock footage of a train
derailing but i thought that might be a
little tacky so i didn't um i just saw
that dj maniac said you just found out
that one of his ex-girlfriends
died
in february and nobody called him
so [ __ ] man i'm sorry to hear that
that's pretty
that's pretty shitty you know but yeah
because they thought you knew look at
poop or nobody thought about it which is
like really
love it what's she doing trying to go
bite [ __ ] stop biting [ __ ] man what a
white my chew on stuff where are your
chicken sticks
what's the matter why are you being so
you're ornery today
she's in her terrible teens i guess well
she's four yeah
what's up with you you know
she's so she already went through
terrible twos now she's terrible fours
but she's a cat so it's like age is
different yeah because she's constantly
getting into [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah you're like a little toddler poopy
that's what you are
go space kitty says
yeah just
just getting into the drink
today
got that pinnacle um
pinnacle coconut and um
pineapple jenny's got uh creamsicle over
there
yeah that's good
today's edition is the manly man edition
the manly man edition
manly man edition is a trap
i see how this is going
people are going to try to and they're
going to be in the comment sections
asking me crazy ass questions and trying
to get me to say [ __ ] that's going to
get the channel banned
because i'll [ __ ] say all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] once i [ __ ] drink it all
right
but even though this shit's crazy that i
say
it's
true of course man
[Laughter]
it's always true you know that's why i'm
always in trouble
i can't lie
i can't lie and keep a straight face
you know
although
i'm starting laughing so maybe although
yeah i was gonna say although like
believing something is true and it
actually being true are two completely
different things i'm on a [ __ ]
journey i
it's not a lie if you believe it
just like well that's i'm pretty sure
that that's exactly what i just said
yeah
but i'm just saying that it's like
those are too completely
he started talking about that the other
night because
um because again pookie was like doing
some [ __ ] she is really into tom's shoes
right thank you no need for me too
here's a hello to get the ball rolling
okay it's gonna take me a minute to get
warmed up yeah we just got here just got
here um
so pookie loves his boots
so the second he like takes them off
she's like oh goody and like she jumps
over there and starts
by the heel she goes out of the heel and
starts pulling on him i kind of raped in
my boots stop raping
scraping and she's getting into it
and she'll pull threads out of him and
everything you know and she but she
knows this the thing is she knows she's
not supposed to do it yeah um so she'll
do it when you're not looking but she
doesn't understand that you can still
hear her yeah and like it makes a
distinctive noise
but i still think she does it just to
get a rise out of you no she forgets she
lust takes over her and she
and she must be like
she must write so she starts raping him
oh like that and when i walk up she
looks oh [ __ ] and then [ __ ] jumps up
and runs yeah and sometimes she can't
get her claw out of the damn background
she's checked on the boat trying to let
go of it it's [ __ ] funny when she
starts going
because she knows she's in trouble
yes i don't know what it feels like
she's such a drama queen because she
knows no one's going to do anything to
her like it's not we're not going to hit
her or anything like that we've never
done that it's just getting caught is
enough
yeah so she gets like well it's just
like if you have like a little a toddler
and he's like happily like drawing all
over the walls and crayon yeah and then
it's like he knows he's not supposed to
but it's just so fun and he can't resist
it and then like he and as soon as you
like catch him doing it he's like oh oh
i didn't do it yeah that's exactly what
pokey does yeah cause she knows what
she's not supposed to do and she knows
what she's supposed to do because like i
said the second like she comes in here
and starts chewing on she has chew
sticks i give her like little chew
sticks that are like have chicken and
catnip on them and stuff but it's like
it's the second she comes in and starts
chewing on cords
all i have to do is take out that bottle
of febreze it could be empty yeah i just
i take the bottle of breeze out she's
like oh [ __ ] and then she like runs out
of the room because she's like oh that's
the that's the hits or thing it hisses
yeah they hate it it's [ __ ] funny
[Laughter]
oh here we go okay sandra's name today
is jean-paul pierre francoise's sister
okay all right now that was the alien
right that was uh the raelian you guys
alien because remember i said like
remember like i made you guess like what
the alien's name was and since the dude
was french you said that his name was
yeah john paul pierre francois yeah
that's my french name
yeah i got a german name too uh what's
that schwannstucker no no no eckhart
eckhart eckhart wolfgang
immelmann
that's my [ __ ] german name that's
just german as [ __ ] all right yeah
that sounds real german when i put that
on i sound i sound like i can do
something it's all i sound real
competent like i invented something you
know
it sounded like you wrote listen like
this really inscrutable tome on like
philosophy or some [ __ ] yeah yeah that's
what it sounds like yeah
and like and like did some questionably
like some ethically questionable
experiments on humans exactly yeah that
sounds like that kind of name eckhart
yeah sorry out there if anybody that's
anyone's actual name el eckhart wolfgang
immelman that's [ __ ] yeah oh yeah we
know about that guy yeah yeah
he was in charge of the 33rd panzer
that's right yeah i remember him
yeah saunders says tom that's quite the
german boomer name that's a blooper name
yeah
yeah
oh my god
that's like that's like the name of my
theoretical grandfather my theoretical
theoretical german grandfather we've all
got one you know yeah
if i had a grandfather that's what his
name is german grandfather that was that
his name would be that yeah all right
yeah
what what brought this up he had a
monocle
okay yeah i like it yeah was he a manly
man oh yeah he he was actually that dude
from [ __ ] young frankenstein
the burger meister yeah that was that
was your that was your like actual
grandfather yeah
yeah yeah
the one with the arm was like yeah yeah
yeah yeah what was it called the
burgermeister yeah he was something
that cop
the wooden arm was like did he put darts
in [ __ ] [ __ ] came in and brought
discipline did you see that [ __ ]
thank you tv triggers tom just says
things that it comes out as gold it does
i know thank you
the poultry guy said it
the uh
he's absolving himself of responsibility
yeah but that dude right there man
[ __ ] uh in that movie i was impressed
with him i wish i had those kind of
skills he just showed up
[ __ ] took charge and [ __ ] laid out
a bunch of discipline and a bunch of
precision
put down some of that prussian precision
on people
and uh
you know
and it solved the crime
didn't he
yeah he figured it out yeah and got and
he got he got the whole town to rise up
against frankenstein yeah yeah
like germans do you know
that's what they're gonna do you know
gonna gather up the torches and they're
gonna go like yeah they're hanging out
in
front of frankenstein's castle they've
been doing that [ __ ] for thousands
they're not standing for them yeah
they've been doing that for thousands of
years man
no tampering in god's domain [ __ ]
right
sandra says my grandfather's name was
otto yeah i actually think otto is kind
of a cool name yeah you know what i mean
is that is that name that seems like a
name that hipsters would give their
babies am i wrong i don't have a sound
it sounds like a hipster baby sandra
said that that that name there was a
[ __ ] german boomer name all right
[ __ ] these new germans those [ __ ]
wearing leather pants and flip-flops and
[ __ ] [ __ ] curly hair perms they're
wearing perms
i'm not approving and listening to uh
david hasselhoff yeah
that has
leather pants
sandals
what is it about that david hasselhoff
thing i don't know his name i think no i
mean i kind of feel like he was a german
american and and i guess the germans
just thought that was [ __ ] cool i
mean he was on knight rider he was
talking to a car
that's right yeah germans they're all
about that
they're going oh yeah we over engineered
it yes yes yes they're over in germans
are over engineering even in america yes
[Laughter]
i don't know that's like that's just
very very funny to me i'm sure it's
probably not relevant anymore but i just
remember hearing like a long time ago
that like germans were super into david
hasselhoff which we thought was very
funny because like we always thought he
was like just super cheesy i think it's
like he was cool when he was on knight
rider kind of
but
after that like he tried to have a pop
music career and america was like uh
yeah no no he wasn't the right kind of
celebrity
i think we're not allowing that
i think the reason why hasselhoff became
popular in germany
it wasn't because of him it was because
of tits boobs
he was on baywatch
that's right i forgot oh my god i forgot
about that it's on baywatch
i'm all like an old person i'm just
thinking about it at that time pam
anderson she was just
you know the pinnacle of [ __ ]
femininity you know she was [ __ ]
super hot
didn't weigh much had perfectly round
implants about three ounces yeah
she had that tattoo going around her arm
and the fake lips the barbed wire yeah
and
and all the rage and i think that i
think those boobs called attention to
hasselhoff
there's a dude named hasselhoff there's
a german american on that program and
somehow or another he capitalized off of
[ __ ] and they're under boobs oh my
god he started yeah he started
capitalizing off pam's boobs and going
to germany and making money he was
bouncing off her boots bounced off her
boobs right over into germany i just
imagine like a little tiny david
hasselhoff wearing a leather jacket and
a scarf like you wore on the berlin wall
when it came down and he was just like
bouncing up and down on pam anderson's
boobs like it was a trampoline he
saxonized he saxonized pam anderson's
boobs for the germans you know he gave
it he made them palatable to the journey
that's what happened
in my mind
[Laughter]
sandra might be able to explain it
you know she might be and what a place
your mind is tom although i can't really
like uh criticize because i have i was
just like picturing a little tiny david
hasselhoff jumping up and down on pam
anderson's boob so i can't really say
anything about it was big though yeah
but he was that they were not but in my
mind he's not in my mind he's like this
size i think hasselhoff was at least six
feet tall
you see he looked tall why did you why
why you want to be no fun but then like
he's too big to jump on her boobs we
need her we need him to be small enough
to jump on her boobs okay that's what
i'm saying so he has to be like this big
so he can go doing going they're saying
you know i'm saying they love the
hasselhoff
it was just kind of like i don't know
it's like really weird it was just kind
of like
um i remember that when i was in wales
and i remembered how much
like the older people in wales [ __ ]
couldn't get enough of tom jones man
like sort of like you know the
generation older than me
um
you go to like any pub
whatever like on a saturday night and
they're playing tom jones and every
drunk ass old person in there is like
singing along
and i'm not [ __ ] on tom jones
because tom jones is actually pretty rad
but i just thought that was like super
super funny he's dead now and he's gone
right
is he dead i think he might be going i
haven't heard of that guy i haven't
heard that guy at all
it's funny because i um we were watching
what uh what's her name like uh joy
jean's channel
emperor's joy jean and uh somebody had
sounded like an old tom jones song like
in the old black and white days
and i had forgotten
uh how [ __ ] awesome because i can't i
kind of feel like i was more familiar
with tom jones with like kind of the
chintzy like vegas era which is still
kind of cool um because i kind of like
that loungy
kind of [ __ ] like that schmalty i kind
of like that but
when um
when he like they she was watching a
video of him like i can't remember what
song it was but it was like an older one
like from the early 60s or something
like that and i was like [ __ ] i forgot
like that dude could really [ __ ] sing
you know what i mean and it wasn't like
all schmalty it was like an actually
like serious kind of song
somebody uh tom jones is alive
um
yeah okay
hasselhoff sandra said that [ __ ]
hasselhoff was looking for freedom
germans love that [ __ ] which i guess
they might be taught she might be
talking about hasselhoff standing on top
of the berlin well yeah that's kind of
like what i was thinking of yeah that's
kind of what i was thinking of yeah
speaking of tom jones that's another
song i sing to pookie sometimes i go
what's new pookie cat yeah
she doesn't know what i'm doing
i try to think of like
um songs that i can put her name into
that i can sing to her but and like the
cheesier the better you know what i mean
like i i really like like barry manilow
or like neil diamond or
abba or something like that but the
problem is it's like i know the songs
but i don't know all the words so a lot
of times i'll just like do the chorus
over and over i have to ask sandra i
don't know you know when i was in when i
was in service
in the in the early part of the 90s
we had a lot of guys that were
joining our unit in the 101st and they
had come from germany mostly ncos
they had a good time in germany they
liked it i went through german germany
on my way to egypt was there for about
probably about uh a day and a half i was
in frankfurt mostly around the hotel
waiting i'm waiting with all these other
[ __ ]
gi's and [ __ ] so i got to see it you
know
traveling from one airport to the next
and going to the little hotel and we
didn't really get to go anywhere we were
locked down
but it looked
cool it looked it looked it was real
high-tech real clean
it was weird it wasn't like an american
city it didn't have like a center to the
city it was spread out you'd have a tall
building over there and another tall
building way over there and one way over
there so it was kind of like you could
tell that it had been
planned
i guess planned uh uh by some kind of
central planning thing it wasn't
something that evolved organically it's
probably blown up in world war two well
yeah i was just gonna say so it was
because remember that little thing that
happened back in the 40s okay right so
there was no downtown that i saw really
you know
but it was kind of cool um
but
some of the guys that i know that i knew
that had come back from there who had
been there for a couple years they had a
great time but they said germans were
just authoritarian they just no matter
what you did
they were just authoritarian if they
they guilt-trip each other a lot and
there's like a right way to do things
and you can't deviate from the right way
to do things and if you're told to do
something you have to do it
whatever whatever the government says
that's what you got to do
you know
we tell you you must do this it's the
right thing you do it
they weren't they weren't really a kind
of a people to go ah [ __ ] you ain't
doing that they're not they're not they
evidently weren't like that
which uh and i i
according i don't know if they're still
like that but
they were saying that these guys who had
lived there
american guys who lived there for a
couple years said that they were always
like that you could go back [ __ ] 200
years they were like that just
kind of like okay
you know they just did whatever they
were told and i don't know if there's if
you guys would still like that sandra
sander probably wouldn't know
actually because it would just seem
normal to her
yeah well sometimes it's like hard to
know it's like you know what your
overriding culture is like if you're not
you know until you're like outside of it
or until you like talk to people that
um have never lived here and like
perceive it in different ways i'm always
like entertained
how
people perceive americans and vice versa
i'm always like really fascinated by how
americans perceive other cultures um
usually incorrectly but you know what i
mean but it's you know it goes both ways
because i think a lot of times but i
think a lot of times you know people
that have never been here they only you
know all of the [ __ ] they see about
american culture
is filtered through our entertainment
which you know is pretty diverse but
it's not
i don't know it doesn't really like
convey what the reality is like on the
ground and the thing is that about
american cultures it's not monolithic
it's really
each state is its own country well even
like even each city is its own thing
it's like everybody's just a mongrel
everybody's from somewhere else and it's
just kind of like
everyone's it's just a very transient
you know immigrant culture you know so
it's there's not really one thing i mean
especially not nowadays i feel like back
in the old back in the day i think there
was kind of like a mainstream culture
sort of but i don't really know if
that's
so much the case anymore
i think it is like to i mean well to a
much lesser extent than it used to be
there's a big difference between cities
and and rural areas rural areas are they
change a lot more slowly than city areas
and that's everywhere well yeah that's
everywhere around the world
right
so you can't really judge america by
cities
cities go in and out of vogue and style
cities actually disappear there are some
cities that are gone you know like gary
is gone
most of detroit is gone
um
there were california towns that are
gone
the little village
that my dad lives in right now
heidelberg it's basically gone
you know i think it had 16 1700 people
in it at one time they all died
it's probably got 400 people in it now
and it's not the same people you know
that village is my dad is the last white
guy
it's all black people
and before it was a german town a german
village but they all just died out
now the black people that live there
you can say what are they immigrants no
they're not immigrants
they've been there for generations and
generations they just moved from another
town
you know what i mean
so in in in rural areas
things kind of go at us down snail's
pace
you know
all the mississippi went like that you
know all the young white people moved
away
of my generation why would you stay
there yeah i mean there's nothing there
there's nothing there like you know if
you want to make a like life for
yourself right
sandra is uh answering your question
about germany she says uh
good lord no not not authoritarian i
would say it's quite the opposite
very open you can do whatever you want
and nobody bothers you um yeah she said
i was in the god scene like 20 years ago
nobody ever bothered them because of
their looks or whatever everybody just
kind of like
did their own thing so you know
i never i i worked with a guy who was in
the military and he had actually been
stationed in germany
pretty much his whole time because he
was in during peacetime
and um he loved it there right he was
always like talking about going back
right well
maybe she's not thinking maybe she's
looking at authoritarianism in a
different way let me ask you this
if germany passes a law do you guys
follow that law do you break that law
well that depends on what the law is
doesn't it
no
no there's some people that would just
follow laws
there are other people that just will
not follow laws they call them criminals
all right
you can see who doesn't follow law by
who's breaking the breaking these laws
and how many of them there are
and how they actually apply to all that
stuff
americans basically don't follow any
laws
you can most of those laws on the books
are being broken on a daily basis we me
and you break all kinds of laws and
don't even realize it yeah but most of
those laws are like from a long time and
they're not even being enforced and no
one enforces them so that's not really
the same thing well it's not really the
same thing it might be
i mean and obviously people follow laws
or no one would be able to drive or walk
down the street or anything i heard
germans just follow laws
that you know to the letter
that they don't break any laws
maybe it's true i don't know well i
don't know like in germany
you'd have to get a driver's license to
drive
all right
technically you would need a driver's
license to drive in the united states
well yeah but most people who do not
have driver's license drive anyway
ask granthars he's a cop
they were pulled over dudes all day long
that are driving that have had their
license suspended or taken away they
still drive
i kind of feel like it's more common to
drive without insurance
um but yeah some people driving upright
well no i know that i know they do i
know they do
because actually um my mom was in a
really bad car accident probably of geez
12 13 years ago yeah and the girl that
hit her did not have insurance
compared to she had a driver's license
but she didn't compare to say the
japanese americans would be considered
lawless
compared to the united states growing up
in brazil
brazilians are lawless compared to the
united states
when i was living in sao paulo brazil
brazil was in a state of anarchy
basically
it had laws but there was no way to
enforce them
you did whatever you wanted to do
okay
prostitution was technically illegal in
brazil prostitution was everywhere
including the prostitution of children
they would do that in public parks with
cops standing right there
that's what kind of place it was they
just didn't give a [ __ ]
yeah well it's it's not like that here
though no you don't see that i mean it
does happen yeah but if you get caught
you'll get arrested and you'll do a lot
of time yeah not with brazil well no i'm
just saying well yeah yeah that's a
that's a difference right brazil was an
anarchy basically you know
um
guns were basically illegal in brazil
but they everybody had them
you know
especially if you were in some kind of
drug cartel then you had ak-47s and
ar-15s and full auto [ __ ]
and um
in in rio rio was controlled by
basically
narco cartels
and they were more they were stronger
than the police the police wouldn't go
in there they were like no-go zones
there's whole um
um what do you call it there's whole um
documentaries on youtube of this
you know there's just places where
those
narco fiefdoms are the government in
certain places in in rio not the
you know
the police and his legal system are just
another one of the factions
yeah it's it's supposed to be supposedly
official but those dudes are just as
corrupt as this as the criminals there's
very little difference
so you know my perspective on the
questions that i'm asking are actually
even a lot more different than yours
actually because your reference is more
american in my reference really
me having such a south american
influence
like you know i talk i talk to
i talk to you know khan all the time and
again
he's down in tijuana mexico and it's
like i'm talking to somebody you know
[ __ ] from my hometown you know the
same kind of thinking
i guess you know so
i can play the american game but for me
it's not really a reality
um
for me i guess because my formative
years were in south america to me that
was reality not so much this this is
kind of like a temporary thing
i feel like you know
this is almost kind of like a false
reality
it's not though i feel like you like
miss out on some stuff because it's like
we don't
you know we just don't you don't live in
that situation anymore yeah but i just
just
you know it feels like i'm in that
situation
you're not though yeah
it's not gonna make it that situation
like that though
can you not no i'm not going to i'm just
saying i could make it that situation
like highly to me it's just because you
know it has to do with the
the zeitgeist because you're okay
because you're a lunatic i'm a lunatic
yeah that's probably why well don't like
drag me down without just saying uh
sandra says much smaller crime rate here
than in the us uh we have prostitution
and it's not illegal yeah i kind of feel
like a lot of uh prostitution is
in europe i don't know like what the
laws are nowadays but i do feel like
it's been decriminalized to a large
degree just like drug use has been which
i really wish they would do here because
it just seems like it would solve a lot
of problems
but you know we'll get there one of
these days or not we're so we're so slow
i don't know but yeah
i don't think they ever will
oh i don't know about that i don't know
about that because
because that particular that particular
profession all right is is now changed
forever as long as there's an internet
because now you don't need the old
school
methods of prostitution which is
standing around a street corner and
brothels you don't need that anymore
this is up there it's all just
independent players on facebook
and and [ __ ] [ __ ] uh
doing business with people on their
friends list
so
they'll never
need to legalize it because there's
other ways to make it happen
well i do kind of feel like now that we
have the internet i do feel like it's at
least gotten a lot safer yeah uh because
they know who it is they're dealing with
yeah or i mean at least you can like
deal with [ __ ] you can be like um you
know uh an independent contractor and
you can do the [ __ ] deal [ __ ] over the
internet you can be an escort whatever
you want to like hang out on a street
corner wait to get murdered
or whatever and it's kind of out of the
public eye
you know what i mean it's out of the
public eye so it's not a public nuisance
nobody knows about it
yeah which like i said i really don't
have i mean i've always agreed with
george carlin on this one uh who said
and i'm
paraphrasing but he basically said uh
you know
sex is legal and it's like you know
selling things is legal [ __ ] [ __ ]
is legal so why isn't selling [ __ ]
legal um yeah it's like he said why
should it be illegal to sell something
that's perfectly fine to give away uh
which you know you can't really argue
with that logic
so
like i said as long as you're not being
forced into it i really don't have a
problem with people wanting to make
money like that i don't think any less
of them i don't think any just you know
do what you got to do man we're all
[ __ ] struggling to make money you
know what i mean yeah so it's like if
you if that's what you want to do then
do it yeah i'm not bothered bees nests
in there [ __ ] tell tom to show that
mexican chick i went to bees man she
said man he's trying to get me to show
pictures of this mexican girl he does
business with
nest bee's nest you couldn't even really
see that girl in that photograph i saw
the video man but is the photo like is
he stalking her no she's sitting in a
window [ __ ] trying to get some
customers
he goes in there and starts talking to
her on the video and she's like yeah
yeah yeah come on he took a picture of
her and [ __ ] but he took he took
a screen capture from the video of him
talking to her that's the old one though
man that one that one was from a couple
months ago
yeah yeah he's saying he's telling me to
pick one out
for him
pick one up yeah yeah yeah because
you're the manly man yeah everything
else i guess you [ __ ] get to deal
with that was over in mexico
like would pick the one you like i don't
like yeah
that'd be like someone else picking out
my clothes i don't like that
yeah right
he needs me to tell him what booty to
jump into
kind of
oh my gosh
all right so
granthar zamber says who is more manly
dennis raider the ordnance compliance
officer or paul blart mall cop
um
gee that's a tough one i don't really
think either one of them are
i really don't want to give points to
dennis raider because he's a serial
killer and
he's just just like a douche all around
yeah um so
i don't know it's like i was thinking
about this earlier because i was
thinking about how esther had like
access to this manly man discussion
um because her and her husband had been
like talking about it
and i was thinking to myself and maybe
this is a glib answer
but i think
being a being manly
is kind of like being cool
if you're like worrying too much about
it are you going to ask people about it
then you're not yeah and and i will say
that for anything because it's like you
know our man buns mainly or this is i'm
like it depends on who's wearing it no
not with ma'am but well no i'm just
saying that i'm just saying using that
as an example because i know that's
something that a lot of people like to
[ __ ] on but it's like i'm always kind of
like look if you're a man and you're
like you know proud of whatever it is
that you have going on then that's fine
it's manly i don't know so people are
like too narrow with it
thank you zach yeah thanks zach it's
read with access
uh hey y'all jenny the research for that
nora fuller script i'm doing is painful
there's so much i need to learn about
the 1900s that i don't care about
i know i'm sorry it's it's like a it's a
horrifying case though
trying to get me to pull [ __ ] why
doesn't minnie dennis offer his opinion
raider comes down when it when it comes
when he wants to channel when his
spirit's trying to channel out of me
channel through me but uh he's not he's
not calling me right now he's not
calling him no he's not calling me
tom tom yeah tom yeah grantham's is
always trying to get me to
compare something with dennis and [ __ ]
well because he's trying to get you
dennis dennis
i'm not really i'm not impressed with
dennis at all you know [ __ ] that dude
is a [ __ ] like i said i read
um the book that sophie sent me that was
all it's called confessions of a serial
killer or a conversa yeah confession of
a serial killer and it was just like all
these like the woman that wrote it was
like in a years-long like correspondence
with the dude and the letters that he
wrote like many of which she reproduced
in the book like you know verbatim
um
that dude i don't understand
at all where that dude is coming from
yeah he's he's a nerd that dude is a
[ __ ] loon don't even don't even
impugn nerds like that i'm kind i'm a
nerd i don't even like want
no it's not nerdiness it's not i don't
even know what it is i can't even
explain it i'm just like what the [ __ ]
are you even like what he's a lunatic
but he's yeah he was a he was a kind of
a nerdy lunatic he there was nothing
really cool about him well no he was not
cool in the slightest there really isn't
any of them that were cool well none of
them are cool that's not that's not a
cool thing to do no well
they're they weren't socially acceptable
really and they had a lot of [ __ ]
problems that's why that's why they were
serial killers there's nothing i could
think of that was cool the closest thing
to a dude that would say that
[ __ ] was manly
[ __ ] tough would have been koklansky
but he wasn't technically he killed a
lot of people he wasn't technically a
serial killer
because he was just doing it as a job
well which that's not good
i'm just saying that it's that's a whole
different dynamic if his story is true
and a lot of it did check out the cops
looked into a lot of it some of it they
couldn't verify
um that dude was a [ __ ] beast all
right
um he did a lot of risky [ __ ] and got
away with it pretty daring assassination
some of them in public
but he said but from what he said you
know he was he says there was no cameras
back then so you could get away with a
lot more
a lot of stuff he was doing back then
you couldn't do it now
um
i don't think he was totally truthful
about everything some of the stuff
didn't didn't sound well he might have
like inflated some [ __ ] to make himself
sound well the torture cave with the
rats and the slow-motion photography i
don't know if that's actually real one
he might have got that from a movie why
hadn't they found that cave you know
they you'd think that they would find
that cave
um or what they would have asked him
where it was and i there wasn't enough
detail in in in in the uh interviews
that i that i was watching uh so i don't
know if that that was true um the other
one would have been uh
the original night stalker that's
you had to have balls to do what he was
doing he was vicious that guy
uh what was his name again d'angelo
d'angelo yeah
allegedly although did he plead guilty
d'angelo was his name yeah that was his
name um no i'm just saying you're
supposed to say allegedly until they've
actually liked that
or
and he fit the profile he he was good
enough to be a cop
for a while i think he got he got
[ __ ] fired eventually i think
yeah it's just i don't know there's like
so much of that there's that certain
type of serial killers that are even and
dennis kind of falls in that too where
it's just kind of like
they just they're like
you know military guys a lot of them are
like in the military and they're either
cops or cop groupies or they're cop
adjacent yeah you know like they like to
security guards or like dennis like he
just they like telling people what to do
it's like a power yeah
now somebody somebody mentioned you know
i saw in the comments before and i said
well that guy was in the military this
was you know [ __ ] dahmer was in the
military you have to understand that
the military changed a lot over times it
there were times there were times in
which basically the military would take
anyone
um and then certain mosses which are
jobs
certain mosses were
real easy to make in certain mosses
like uh i think actually wasn't um
berkowitz military for a while
he might have been now that i'm thinking
about it a lot of them were but i kind
of feel like that was kind of something
a lot of people did back then so i don't
know if it was during the draft
yeah that was during the draft times
standards were real low
and the guys that were pretty good
ended up in some kind of uh well
and good means can mean different things
you know what i mean if the guy was real
intelligent and had uh
uh special skills he went to a support
unit somewhere you know he was doing
something high-tech that he didn't
really go into combat the the easy
training they did they weren't trying to
flush those guys out through a survival
of the fittest type
process of elimination you know what i
mean it was a civilian type job here do
this push these buttons fill this thing
out you know it's that kind of [ __ ] well
yeah because they need support roles
they need support so it's like not
everybody is yeah they're not trying to
kick them out right
um
so
very different
from say
special forces when i was in special
forces or season when i was in
the infantry special forces
was the equivalent of like pro football
the your chances of getting in there
were about zero they had all the guys
they needed they were only to even if
you made it through selection
and you say they had 100 guys going
through the selection process two of
them might make it and out of those two
they'd pick one
they just didn't need replacements
you know because it's a 20-year contract
so they're in there forever and they get
paid a lot of money they make over a
hundred thousand dollars a year
because there's all this tdy money and
all this training money and
travel money and hazardous duty pay
money jump status pay they they make a
lot of money and then they as soon as
you get through selection and everything
they make you like an e6 or an e7 so you
got you know nobody's under i think the
i think nobody's really under uh
uh what was
stat staff sergeant i guess yeah staff
sergeant i guess
um
isn't that what it was called or
sergeant first class no i can't remember
the ranks now the one with the three
stripes up and the one on the bottom i
think was called staff sergeant
i think that was the if you could be an
e5 when you got out of
selection
and
no you when you got out of selection and
then when you were in the queue course
by the time you had a q course you were
an e5 then you would end up being an e6
as soon as you got sent to the unit and
that was this that was their lowest rank
that was already making a lot of money
with all the extra [ __ ] on top of there
so
then they were in there for 20 years
and then when they got out
they'd go for these [ __ ] heists uh
these really high-paid private security
companies
would pick them up and they made several
hundred thousand dollars a year as
bodyguards
for you know
famous people and elite people and
politicians and they'd end up doing the
[ __ ] that [ __ ] probably you couldn't
talk about you know
[ __ ] for all you know they end up
getting training as a [ __ ] private
investigator and a bunch of law
enforcement training and out
assassinating people
you know for some politician somewhere
in in another country
dude what find this dude
find this dude and kill him he's got a
[ __ ] lawsuit against me yes sir i'll
take care of that three or four you go
down there and [ __ ] i would abuse
that [ __ ] power what's that i would
abuse that [ __ ] but yeah
some of that might be happening here in
the united states i got some evidence
that that some of that you know just by
reading newspapers that some of that's
happening here
um
politicians doing that to each other
that's just it was happening in ancient
rome they did the same thing you know
um
don't get caught black opera special
operations are black operations they're
black because they're illegal they're
crimes
and if you get caught nobody supports
you
you got to kill yourself
yeah so you know if you're getting into
that line of work just just a pro tip
got to be ready to do that yeah got to
put your tooth down on that cyanide
catholic yeah blow your own head off
well i know they don't do that yeah i
was just making a joke or you forced law
enforcement to kill you
you don't survive you don't you know
what i mean yeah you go down fighting
ghostface kitty says is marilyn manson
manly no
well i don't know i guess i don't i
don't know it's hard for me to say
because he's kind of douchey but it's
like i don't know he never was he's a
good entertainer pat hatfield says bruce
campbell okay like i i think bruce
campbell is totally manly
you're asking a woman though
all right women will think all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] yeah we'll see
women's standards well see this is what
i think of i always think like a dude
standards of manliness are like this big
whereas like a woman standard manly this
is like this big there's like a lot of
there's a lot of wiggle room in here
like i said there's there's a lot of
[ __ ]
honestly as long as you're not a creep
you're not a dick you're like you have
something to offer
and you're kind of like
cool with how you are
then that's cool
like to me that's fine
i don't really think like i don't think
there's this little narrow thing it's
like oh they have to be able to do this
then the other thing that just i don't
know it seems really reductive and
insulting to men really i think i think
it's insulting to men
but you know maybe that's just me maybe
it's just me i just kind of feel like
it's very very narrow band i'm not into
it yeah i'm not into it yeah i ain't
gonna say anything i guess
well you've been saying [ __ ] you've been
dancing
look
there's a lot of different kind of men
in the world you know what i mean or
dudes like mozart all right that's what
i'm saying and then there are dudes like
the rock and [ __ ] yeah both of which are
awesome yeah all right oh it's awesome
but when you're looking at when you're
looking at things from just like the
hyper masculine viewpoint all right
you're gonna say the rock is really you
know what i mean what
is more manly than
well what is a man well that's what i'm
saying i it was like i said i think the
definition is too narrow
i think the definition is
i think people have too many
rules about it
and i think they are silly
i'm just going to say that right now
well i think it's a woman would say that
though but a woman would say that
like you the people who are
very different standard of what a man is
okay
for me a man is a dude that you want to
have next to you when [ __ ] goes bad
okay
when [ __ ] goes bad you need somebody
that can [ __ ]
fight right alongside you somebody who's
got skills somebody who is not dead
weight that you and him together are
equaling more than the some of us both
it's kind of like spock and kirk
but see i kind of feel like that's true
of humans in general
not just men right i don't want to like
if i'm like if i get abandoned out in
the woods with some other chick i don't
want her to be some useless ass i'm
gonna have to drag around either right
you know what i mean so
either way if i'm in a [ __ ] fist
fight or a fire fight and [ __ ] you don't
want marilyn manson with you all right
that motherfucker's gonna be dead weight
i don't know because he might just like
poop on you and people would be like
grossed out and then they'd run away
madison would [ __ ]
[Laughter]
he would do exactly the wrong thing
so there are different kinds of guys for
different types of situations
okay
the best case scenario is a guy who can
do who's a generalist he's not a
specialist he's a generalist he can do a
little bit of everything he's good at
certain things that [ __ ] are real
important but he
he he can fit into
any mold at least temporarily to get
through something that's really
what i noticed made the difference
but there's a couple of key things you
got to be really good at everything
boils down to endurance
endurance
and willpower
the most important thing is you can't be
with a [ __ ] who quits
if you quit you lose
you just lose you wanna you want a
[ __ ] who never quits
you understand what i'm talking about
well no but like i'm saying no you don't
understand you said no
you want to be with me can i never quit
when i finish what i'm saying or not
okay no i was what i was gonna say was
that but that's true of like anybody
um yeah not just a dude because like i
said i don't want to be hanging out with
some chick that's like that either okay
well see you have to take the you have
to take people
and put them in a certain type of
situation and see who quits first
and you got and then who's quitting and
then how long can they all do it who's
the last one to quit and you can rank
them that way
that's really
all this [ __ ] military training
really
is actually just that to see who quits
and who doesn't and then the guys who
don't quit you continue to [ __ ]
stress them out until they all break
because eventually everyone will break
you know what i mean
pretty much you just try to
you just want to see which of the last
ones to to break and you can kind of
yeah well like i said and i don't even
think that's unnecessarily just manly
virtue i think that's just like a human
virtue you just want somebody that's not
going to give up at the first like sign
of how do you discomfort or something
like that how do you know you got to put
them through those tests most people are
not tested
they're just not yeah but i'm just
saying that that's good for anybody yeah
that's all it would mean that for
anybody in my in my experience
again most people most people [ __ ]
most people just walking around in some
maul somewhere you don't want them
you want some unusual [ __ ]
yeah although like you said you never
really know until because some people
never really can actually surprise you
you never really know until you see it
yourself
and that's why
if you have a military or law
enforcement background
you know the dudes you served with you
saw what they did you knew who they were
you saw you saw them at their best and
at their worst so you know exactly what
they're gonna do so that's an advantage
that guys like us have now this also
could probably go into the sports realms
with those jocks and all their [ __ ]
little sports stuff
they're going through a similar process
all right
so the
it ends up forging like a brotherhood
between these dudes that really lasts a
lifetime
like i know what everybody's doing you
know i talked them on my a.g sparks his
house burnt down a couple weeks ago
lot two of his three of his dogs died in
it because no don't tell me stuff like
got a smoke inhalation because they were
in the cage he had him caged because he
was having a party in the house and
somebody let off fireworks in the house
the house caught on fire wait who is it
who is he inviting that's letting out
fireworks in the house yeah he had like
30 people in the damn house all right
that's don't let up fireworks in the
house i mean i shouldn't have to tell
you a nice neighborhood like this
living in a nice neighborhood like this
what [ __ ] did that
i didn't ask him because it might have
been him
but he went in there and saved a whole
bunch of people ran into that damn house
he said visibility was zero and and he
he knew his way around just by feel
because it was his own house
and he was getting people out of that
house that were trapped in there and the
house just [ __ ] vanished within
minutes
well see i would do that yeah
if the house was burning down and pookie
was in here i am not leaving without he
had to get people out he was gonna i'm
not leaving without spooky or beijing
either he said the dogs were gonna go
last
but the um they were already they're
already dead in the smoke inhalation by
the time he got everybody out
okay no it depends on which people are
in the house it was just a bunch of
people
okay but he didn't i didn't ask any
questions but i was proud of him that he
got it all done [ __ ] you know what i
mean there was other guys with him but
he said he just he said he he knew the
layout of the house and he just
it just took over him
he didn't even think about it he just
well yeah going into the house honestly
i think most people would probably do
that if it was their own house they knew
their family was in there or even or
their pets or whatever and like i said
pets are family too so it's like if your
[ __ ] house was burned down and your
kids were in there [ __ ] yeah like 99
percent of people would run in there
no i'm just saying like no i'm just
saying that yeah most people but you're
you know if it was your kids or your
friends or your spouse or whatever i
think most people would probably run in
there to get them i don't see you know
most people yeah a lot more die too well
yeah but it's like that's something that
you know
what do you
what are you say the smoke was so bad he
couldn't see he had to get down on the
ground
get underneath the smoke yeah that's
what you do yeah
uh gildan age phoenix says women can
openly define what a man is but men are
not supposed to define what a woman is
see i don't think that's true though
because i'm not really defining what a
man is in fact i'm expanding the
definition because i think the
concept of manliness is too limited and
i'm kind of saying i'm not defining
anything i'm just saying like do be what
you want and it's just like be cool with
it that's all i'm saying i'm not saying
like oh a man has to be this that the
other thing
i don't really
that's like i said that's not for me to
decide i'm not a dude you know what i'm
saying
and it's
honestly i guess it comes from a place
where because we were kind of talking
about this a little bit last night we
were re-watching um
uh toys that made us because we i kind
of i think like a lot of people were
because movies that made us season two
just like came out
so then toys that made us was trending
again even though there's not new ones
out so a lot of people are rewatching it
so we re-watched some of the episodes we
watched like the barbie one and the
he-man one and stuff like that
we were kind of talking about
um you know the differences in like the
way that little boys and little girls
like played with toys in general and i
was kind of like
i don't know i always kind of felt like
like i liked some girl toys like i had a
couple of barbies and [ __ ] like that but
it wasn't really my favorite thing
um i liked girl toys and boy toys about
equally i might have liked boy toys a
little bit better because at least they
had like monsters and [ __ ] because i
really liked monsters and [ __ ] so i just
kind of feel like
my whole life i got kind of told that
like i wasn't
feminine enough because i liked scary
stuff
and i liked some things that were boy
things
um even though i liked some things that
were girl things too
so
i really feel like i don't have any
right to tell other people like what's
masculine or feminine because i mean i
never really cared if [ __ ] was like
feminine and i'm like i don't care i
just like this kind of [ __ ] you know
what i mean like when i was a kid i had
i was thinking about this earlier i had
do you guys remember like in the i guess
it was like late 70s they had those
things called um what are they called
fashion plates and you had it was like
little different outfits and you could
like mix different heads with like
different tops and different skirts and
stuff and i had that
but my brother also had this monster one
and i liked that one just as much so we
used to kind of like mix them together
and like make hey let's put like this
woman's head but then like give her like
a mech suit like at the top and then
like she has werewolf legs and it's like
so that kind of thing so i kind of liked
a mixture of all the things before so
fourth drawer down asked is a segway a
manly mode of transportation
if you have to ask that question then
[ __ ] uh you're wrong dude course of
course not of course not
honestly i really don't think a segway
is like any kind of but like i
understand that it's like
thank you zach one of my favorite things
on youtube is a stop-motion animated
series where barbie is an alcoholic sex
addict who can't remember her kids names
behind the scenes oh my god i need to
like [ __ ] watch that in general
a segway of course you know that's some
real urban type stuff that's like
that's something you would ride around i
mean i wouldn't be caught dead on there
that was something you ride around in an
office with a ride down the street you
know that's something you'd have to go
down newberry street you know in boston
or some [ __ ] like that which uh of
course no that's not that's not macho at
all not at all
in in fact
manliness
is actually kind of like at a higher
premium in in in a rural setting
it just is
it's you need a lot more
rugged individualism
in a city
you can have a job and make money and
pay taxes and have strong men like me
and granters defend you from bad people
you know what i mean [ __ ] because you
know you can't defend yourself other men
have to do it for you that's what that's
all about
out in the country right there's a
police station but that's a long ways
away you gotta [ __ ] take care of
yourself out there
that's why they're all carrying guns
and now sandra said in germany there is
no guns and she's lying there's lots of
guns in germany i know the gun laws
there or i did
there's a lot of private gun owners in
germany it's just that they have to have
one you have they have to have a safe
they have to uh go through a bunch of a
registration uh thing
and um
uh i think they're they're on a pretty
big way they have to go through like a
training course and a certain waiting
list that they go through
but no they got guys in germany that
have
assault rifles and pistols and a lot of
the same stuff that you would get here
in the united states i don't even think
i don't think noise suppressors are
illegal in germany you just need uh this
proper license they're not illegal here
you just need a permit for them all
right it's not even a permit it's a tax
stamp 200 tax step you can get it which
they may get rid of that because there's
no reason
for
sound suppressors to be illegal or
controlled really
that was from another era and it was had
nothing to do with crime it had to do
with poaching animals and that times
passed that was great depression stuff
um so no they have they have lots of
guns in germany
it's just that they have to go through
uh
they have to go through a couple little
hurdles to get them you have to really
want one
it's more expensive
so it ends up being where if you're rich
you can get one in germany if you're
poor you can't have one but if you're
rich you can do anything if you're rich
you can do anything so because laws
don't apply to you right it's not a
pride of you you're making the laws
other people are following that's what i
mean so yeah
uh so aaron says are rollerblades manly
i haven't seen anybody like well okay
there's one person i've seen one person
that still uses rollerblades like on the
trail outside where i do my uh walks or
whatever
but i only see them every now and then
um
on the whole it seems like rollerblades
are not are they even a thing anymore i
kind of feel like that was like a trend
for a time i even remember i remember
somebody in my family my brother
probably i think he got some for
christmas or his birthday or something
and uh
man i remember doing those and i'm just
like holy [ __ ] i'm gonna like break my
ankles even though i'm like really good
at roller skating
but
rollerblades not so much yeah
you're yeah
you're wrong
i know i
i've actually talked to german guys
there's videos of them you can have them
it's just that there's
a different process you have to go
through
uh it costs more money you have to have
a safe and you have to have a bunch of
stuff
and but no they got guys that got them
and it's legal
and you're saying law enforcement how do
you define law enforcement
you know who is law enforcement
is a private investigator law
enforcement
is uh
you know there's a lot of things that
are kind of like law enforcement what if
you're a private security agent
like here here's this is what i'm
talking about senator you're not
you a civilian
now i have to be careful what i'm saying
here because certain machine guns are
transferable because they were before
the certain 1986 five law happened there
are certain machine guns because of the
date of manufacture
can be transferred from one owner to the
next
okay
but they stopped that
the only way you can have a full auto
weapon
in the united states is if you have
a contract with a military or law
enforcement
a military or law enforcement
organization you can sell it to them if
you're a manufacturer okay
a manufacturer has the right to make
what's called a dealer sample or a
manufacturer's sample
to become a manufacturer you have to
[ __ ] get a certain class 3 license so
you can get a license you can become a
licensed manufacturer and make yourself
a sample
and that sample is yours
that's how you get a machine gun in the
united states
every guy who has one
is legally a manufacturer and he can
make his own samples
there's always a way around anything
or you can have what was called a
transferable transferable i think it's
pre 1984.
uh but then there's all other kind of
things if you're ex-military and you're
you you've done contract work uh there
certain states will allow you to have
certain things there's all kinds of
different ways to get anything the
hardest thing to get the united states
is called dd destructive device
which is grenades
rocket launchers any tank weapons those
those are harder to get but even those
you can get if you work for the right
companies
security companies
okay
i was gonna say like you know what is
not manly trying too hard to be manly
it's just kind of like well if you're
trying every well that's what i mean
every time we're driving to the street
and it's like i kind of feel like most
people have this and you see this dude
in this like [ __ ] enormous
like 4x4 truck with those big like truck
tires and stuff like that the first
thing everybody thinks is that he has a
micro dick yeah because you're over
compensating
like i said you got to like not
there's a fine line to draw between
being
just like a regular ass like manly man
who's just like confident in your
whatever in your manhood and you can
just like do what you want to do and not
like worry about what other people think
about you which to me like i said seems
manly and then you can go way over into
like performative manliness where you're
going like way over the top and you're
just like i have to have this big huge
truck and this big huge this that this
with all the [ __ ] rifle rack on the
back and all this other kind of [ __ ]
which
just kind of makes me think that maybe
you have some insecurity issues
that's all i'm saying
i just kind of feel like there's a lot
of that going on but you know
yeah if you try hard that means you're
not
exactly that's what i'm saying it's just
like being cool you can't like go around
telling people how cool you are because
obviously that's really not cool
cool is like
not it's an indefinable quality
and you can't try to do it
you just it just has to like happen
it has to be like natural it has to be
organic and i kind of feel like it's the
same thing
with that kind of [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying you know
oh my god all right so uh yeah do or do
not there is no try yeah it's you know
it's that kind of thing
just
yeah like don't try so hard nobody likes
a tryhard that's kind of like what
i don't even i don't care what it is
that you're doing what your vibe is
what you think what your whole thing is
what your gestalt is
um but just do that and own it
and then that's fine
just don't try to be something you're
not that's all
i kind of feel like that's
and everything everybody else just need
to like chill out about it don't try
hard
that's all
what are you doing i was gonna show her
that this guy right here
this guy here will tell you how to get
any kind of legal guns in germany that
that's a journey that's a german guy
he's got a bunch of them
but no there are ways to get the
licenses
name of that channel is
george sprov what is that
well i don't quit moving it
it wouldn't you complain to me no i said
it won't you it won't focus if you don't
stop moving it yeah
you can't just wave it around it'll just
stay blurry
i'm just telling you
the name high camera the video is can
germans have guns sure things weapon law
in germany weapons laws in germany
in germany in germany
[Laughter]
are you drunk already no
i could use another one
he said you have to get things like
collector's licenses
and uh hunter's licenses
and then there's a bunch of other things
that you can get he's got he's got a
german assault rifle an
hk91 2.
yeah oracle says be the best you that's
honestly that's kind of like
that should be like the zen cone for all
of life
yeah and it's honestly it's taken me
like a really long time to get to that
because i always kind of felt like i
don't know i was i always kind of felt
like i was doing something wrong or i
was like
not because you know i was kind of a
weird kid and
i'm a weird adult
like so it's and it's weird when you
always have somebody like like people
telling you or
implying to you that you're like not
normal you're not doing something right
or something like that so it's like when
you grow up like that
um
even if no one's being outright shitty
to you
just the vibe you get from people is
like well
you know
maybe you should be more like this or
maybe you should be more like that like
when you grow up like that it's like
really
you grew up like that well it's kind of
a thing where like i said i
my parents were not terribly bad uh my
dad was kind of i'm not even gonna get
into that whole situation
but um
you know she was kind of a tomboy
yeah but not though because it's like i
still liked girl [ __ ] but i also really
liked boy [ __ ] and i really liked scary
[ __ ] which was my main thing um whether
it was girl [ __ ] or boy [ __ ] i was like
i just want scary [ __ ] i want wit [ __ ] i
want ghost [ __ ] i want all that kind of
[ __ ] i want monsters so it's like i like
that kind of [ __ ] so it's like i kind of
feel like a lot of people particularly
back in the 70s and 80s they didn't
really know how to deal with a girl
that was into that kind of thing yeah so
even if they weren't like outright
hostile
um it was always kind of like
okay
it was always like that kind of
situation now senator john says well yes
hunters can have guns well of course
hunter's gonna that's the same as having
a gun that's the same thing as having a
gun center
there's a there's just different kind of
licenses that you need to get in germany
but those guys that have their [ __ ] they
were showing it it was all nice [ __ ]
it's just that they go through the
proper licenses different german
licenses to get
it's the same [ __ ] you get here in the
united states
just that we don't need those licenses
probably time for another drink all
right yeah yeah we're not that far in
okay
yeah so it's just kind of like
like i said i got picked on in school
later um
no need for me to says jenny's
complicated
you don't even know the half of it but
uh yeah so it's not so much that you get
like i got bullied
later probably like starting maybe late
elementary school or junior high
um
where you got picked on well i
particularly got picked on for being shy
for being poor
that was the big one uh for being smart
and nobody likes that so you know i got
picked on being like that but it's kind
of like
i don't know i always kind of felt like
growing up like i said
they didn't really have a context i
think it's easier nowadays because it's
like everybody understands that now like
girls some girls like like horror [ __ ]
um but back in the 70s and 80s i don't
really think there was
it was just kind of like the goth thing
where a lot of people didn't really have
the context
so they didn't really know
what to do with you because you didn't
like fit into any of the slots that they
had it's like oh we don't
you know they they didn't know any other
little girls in the family that were
like into like monsters and [ __ ] so it
was kind of like they didn't really know
what to do about it like they weren't
like i said no one was like hostile in
my family necessarily but sometimes they
would try to
steer me into different things sometimes
there was i mean i had a thing where
even when i was going off to college
like my grandfather
he offered to like pay
for my first uh couple semesters at
college but he didn't want me to do
anything
artistic he didn't want me to do graphic
design which is what i was going in to
do
because he thought you couldn't make any
money doing that
which is dumb because i made i
never had problems getting jobs doing
that so and i still make money doing it
nowadays
so he wanted me to do accounting and i
was just kind of like
no
i don't want to do that so it's like he
only paid for my first two so you know
he's dead now so i don't want to say
anything bad about it but
he only paid for my two first two
semesters he's like well yeah if you're
just gonna do this already [ __ ] i don't
want to like pay for it so he didn't pay
for it so i had to get a [ __ ]
i got a grant after that happily but
it's just it was like that kind of thing
like no one wanted to like you know
because she's like the weirdo she's a
weirdo
so sandra is a chandra said people can't
have guns but hunters can have guns as
if hunters aren't people if hunters can
have the guns and that means people can
have guns sandra
hunters are people
if you want a gun just become a hunter
or you know there's all kinds of other
ways
that guys had a whole bunch of them you
just they're just different licenses
here's another [ __ ] weird thing
i never mind
i don't want to go through the intricate
intricacies of [ __ ] um
[ __ ] what do you call it nfa national
firearms act the united states has
stupid gun laws
you know like
you can't have a sound suppressor
without paying this 200 tax
they do a little background check and if
you're not a criminal then
they'll let you have the suppressor for
200 bucks it's a tax on top of it why
why
you know it's well
because it's a suppressor well what's
wrong with suppressor
well it's a suppressor so it needs 200
bucks you might be james bond with a
silencer no it's not what it is
back in the great depression you had
people's taking suppressors and putting
them on 22 caliber
bolt-action rifles and going out and
shooting rabbits and
and
shooting rabbits and shooting uh
squirrels and they were shooting so many
of them
uh that they were depleting the
livestock and
the
the game wardens wanted to make limits
on how many little these little animals
you could kill a day and if you were had
that suppressor on there you could go
over your limit because they were
listening for gunshots that's how the
the wardens found you had nothing to do
with crime
if you put a suppressor on a nine
millimeter pistol or
and and shoot through that even with
subsonic ammo a 22 long rifle or any
other pistol is still louder than that
it doesn't make it silent so you're not
hiding the fact that shots were fired
it's stupid i mean
if a nine millimeter suppressor requires
a suppression
tax well wouldn't a 22 caliber pistol
require it it produces less decibels
you know that's quieter than that so it
doesn't make any sense well you might
assassinate somebody
well [ __ ] it doesn't [ __ ] matter you
can [ __ ] fire off an unsuppressed
nine millimeter [ __ ] pistol in a
house and the neighbors won't even hear
it it didn't matter if it had a
suppressor on it or not
you can fire off a 556 rifle in the
house
and the neighbors wouldn't know what
that was you don't need a suppressor on
that either
you know you don't it's just [ __ ]
silly people worry about [ __ ] too much
esther says i was bullied from
elementary school to high school yeah
it's kind of like
i don't know i kind of i felt like i was
in elementary school like my teachers
loved me
because you know i actually liked school
and i liked learning things and i was
well behaved and quiet and i wasn't an
[ __ ]
but other kids you know not all of them
but there are some other kids they don't
like you if you're quiet they don't like
you if you're bookish they don't like
you if you're smart they don't like
other things like that
also like i said you know
i grew up fairly poor so it's like all
my clothes were like secondhand i didn't
really or third hand uh so i didn't wear
anything that was like fashionable or
anything so and i went to a school that
was kind of
uh a little bit above
where i lived uh you know what i mean so
a lot of those kids were kind of like
upper middle class and i was very
working class so that was kind of
another thing junior high was probably
worse i got picked on a lot for being
poor for being a weirdo high school
wasn't too bad i still got picked on
from being a weirdo but at least like i
had other
you know i had a handful of other
weirdos that i hung out with so it
wasn't quite so bad um you know because
we were all getting picked on together
so it was fine but you know uh dj maniac
says i got picked on for being a nerd a
goth a weirdo and now that i'm 44 it
hasn't [ __ ] changed a bit yeah it's
like
it's better now obviously but
it's still
growing up like that for like years and
years
you just kind of get this sort of thing
where now it's like for example like if
we're at mannequins or something like
that and there's like some group of like
basic you know kind of [ __ ] there
and they start like making fun of so
even if they're not even making fun of
me but if they're like making fun of
somebody that i know that's like dancing
on the dance floor like being gothy or
whatever and it's just like
that still just fills me with
rage
to this day and i'm almost 50 years old
[ __ ] look at sandra sanders says well
you can't just be a hunter here you
can't call yourself a hunter you got to
go to like a hunter's school with exams
and [ __ ] it's [ __ ] funny then she
goes well
germany's not authoritarian so germany
tells you when you're a [ __ ] hunter
or not that's ridiculous my dad just
taught me you know that was just the way
we grew up
um
it's still what all that is is a is is a
hurdle another hurdle but to to getting
what you want you just take that you
just study for that and take that test
that's no big deal just do it
germans don't want you driving either as
far as i understand i heard i heard that
learning how to drive a car in germany
and passing that test is about like
about like it is for [ __ ] flying a
cessna airplane
which
not in the united states the united
states if you decide your name they give
you a [ __ ] driver's license yeah well
that's not entirely not it
but the test is way easier the contest
is just driving around the block which i
don't think i don't think that's good
though no it's not good it's not good
but because now like we have all these
[ __ ] idiots on the road that don't
[ __ ] know how to drive yeah but a lot
of them though
are doing that because they come from
south america south americans [ __ ]
drive like maniacs i go that's a
brazilian i could tell just by the way
they died that dude's [ __ ] driving
style
and the thing is is that if you were to
actually make them past that test they
would just say you were racist they
forget some [ __ ] like that you know well
and the well the thing about the driving
test is that i don't know if people know
this but it's different everywhere you
go yeah
my
not even each state each county town it
can't be true
yeah because my ex-husband who was
british yeah uh he had a driver's
license in the uk um it took him two
times because they have to do like a
whole you have to pay for like lessons
and stuff yeah and then you take the
test and it's hard um he passed it the
second time so he had a driver's license
over there but it's like when he came
over here they're like well yeah we
don't care that you have a license over
there so you have to like take the test
over here he took the test in daytona
where we lived at the time and he was
[ __ ] amazed he's like all i had to do
was take a test on a computer and then
drive around a parking lot and they gave
me a [ __ ] license he's like they
would never do that over there now when
i took it i actually
uh
hired a lady and she gave me some
lessons
um and then and she was british actually
which is weird and i took lessons for a
couple of weeks and i'm just like okay
that's fine but when she gave me the
test we drove to uh i think it was
seminole county
and on their test you actually had to
drive on the road and you had to drive
on the highway and you had to like merge
into traffic you had to do all that kind
of stuff you had a parallel park you had
to do all that kind of [ __ ] so that was
like one county over
so
it wasn't just if i had taken the test
in daytona i could have just driven
around a parking lot but i was like yeah
i don't really want to do that i would
rather like drive on an actual road
um
sandra says yeah but we we actually
don't have speed limits here on the
autobahn we don't have speed limits here
in florida either
70 it's posted 70 but i'll be going 70
or 80 sometimes down as long as you're
not going demonstrably faster than
everyone else like 105 110 now if you do
that
you will get pulled over if you get seen
yeah if they see you yeah but you can if
if the flow of traffic is going 80 85
and you're just going with it and you're
not being egregiously like then you can
then i've been going 80 85 miles an hour
and looked over and there's a car and
there's a cop going 85 right next to me
and then somebody passes us at about
[ __ ] 90. it's not unusual to go 80 85
on the highway they don't get if there's
not a lot of traffic and honestly i used
to because i used to work at night yeah
uh and i worked i lived in uh orlando
but i worked in daytona for a little
while but i worked the night shift so i
would be coming back at like three four
in the morning
um and there was nobody on i-4 which is
the only time i will ever drive on that
[ __ ] road because it's a nightmare um
so i'd be coming back just listening to
music or whatever and i'd be going like
100 110 and [ __ ] like that and it's like
i never got pulled over no ever not in
florida florida does not give a [ __ ]
about that speed but like i said if
you're in
if you're in heavy traffic and you're
pulling that [ __ ] yeah and leaving in
and out and if a cop sees you yes they
absolutely lend rightfully so because
that's endangering other people me and
granters we learned to drive at the
[ __ ] same time same place that was a
[ __ ] trenton high school we learned
how to drive in high school we had a
driver's education class you had to get
up at five o'clock in the morning and
sit out there
freezing ass cold [ __ ] weather and do
all your driving about an hour before
school started and we had a little
driver's school i think we even had to
pay for that you didn't have a class
i had a class you had to do both in high
school yeah there's a class and then you
had to drive but then later drive yeah
yeah in high school i did but then later
i kind of didn't i didn't have money for
a car so then later i kind of forgot and
so like i paid a woman for a couple of
weeks to like re-teach me how to drive
because my dad wouldn't do it so you
know germany would be germany would be
impressed because we had our driver's
license i think by the time we were 16.
we were driving
i think we had permits at 16. well you
can get a permit at 15. 15. that's what
it was you can get a permit at 15 but
you can't drive like generally
we 15 or 16 when when we go at least in
florida yeah and then at least when i
was growing up in florida you can get a
permit at 15 but
you can't drive after dark unless you're
going to and from work then it's allowed
and
usually unless you're going to or from
work you have to have a licensed driver
in the car with you um you can get a
regular license at 16.
the thing is though is that i remember
that once we came out of there the
permit was only like
for about five or six months and then
you then you got your real yeah it was
six months well you didn't have to drive
for the permit you just had to take the
written test oh no we had to drive for
the we had to drive for the permit well
not in florida you didn't no we i don't
know about now but back then you didn't
back in back and
unless grand grandson of grampus was
there man he maybe he'll correct me
because what you're saying let me finish
what i'm saying let me finish i'm saying
no we yes i'm talking okay go ahead what
you're doing
is you take the written test to you you
know all the signs you know the rules
when you're 15. yeah you're supposed to
get the permit so that you can learn to
drive in that year and then get your
regulator that's how that's how florida
not in michigan that's how florida in
michigan you took you you were in a
class and you had to take like little
written tests in the class
okay yeah we did and then you would
drive
and you had the instructor with you in
the car yeah we did drive around
and then
i think you got the permit
there
no see for our classes let me tell you
what i'm saying
then you you got your permit it came in
the mail
and then for like six months
and then
six months later you i think we got the
real license and that means that you
could drive it dark after dark
no what you were supposed to do like i
said was that when you were fifteen
different state jenny i know that but
i'm just saying in florida when you were
15 you were actually supposed to have
the permit
before you took driver's ed because
drivers had the class in high school
which was free uh it was just like
another elective you could take yeah
um you were supposed to have the the uh
permit at the beginning of the semester
yeah not not missing so that you could
drive
you know and then at the end of the
semester you were supposed to go and
take your test
in michigan you did all your testing
your driving and then you got your
permit
and then you could drive for about six
months and then it got upgraded into a
license
where it was like a regular because i
think our teacher was
i think he was able i think he was he
was licensed by the state to [ __ ]
approve you to [ __ ] get well yeah
ours was too to get you your license but
you started off as it was a temporary
permit
well yeah that's right yeah you got a
permit yeah at the beginning of the year
when you were 15. you're right and it
lasted for about six years you just took
a written test and got a permit right
and then you took the class
and then you drove in the parking lot or
in the thing and then at the end of the
semester you got your life your regular
license we had to do all kinds of
[ __ ] classroom study yeah we did that
and we had to [ __ ] drive and then
take the test which is the driving test
and then they gave you your permit
and then six months later i think it was
upgraded into a license and it just came
in the mail
that's how it was well yeah ours did too
but i'm just saying that i don't know
what the per no the permit they just
gave it to you with just a written test
you don't have to drive to get a permit
in michigan you had to drive and you did
the whole driving test you were expected
it was a temper it was a temporary
driver's license yeah that's what you
passed the test
you had passed the driving test here you
only had to pass a written test
take care of that you had to do the
driving test and everything and then
they gave you a temporary license like
six months
and then it upgraded if
that's how i remember it and grab this
was in there that [ __ ] did the same
program with me through the same high
school we all did it he would remember
i don't remember that's how that's how i
remembered it being i mean it might be
totally different because as soon as i'm
just saying there's another state no i'm
just saying michigan no i'm saying in
florida it might be totally different
now i don't know that was a long time
ago here's the thing
we had we had even on that permit
you could drive at night under a lot of
different circumstances
yeah you could here too you could drive
you could still drive it if you were
going to and from work right and then
then i think you were allowed to drive
on the weekends
which wait a minute hold on what
so you would think that the weekends
would be the highest risk one was
because i remember going on dates on the
permit
driving my date around
on a permit i remember that
and that was weekend
it might have been i don't really
remember that like it might have been
like that here too i just i don't really
remember just didn't watch it all i
remember was that i remember that the
nighttime drivings was no inconvenience
at all
because i remember being horrified of
being like okay so these 15 year olds
you're not even going to let them
actually drive a car you're just going
to like let them pass a written test and
you're going to let them drive around on
the roads
with other people
um
sandra's saying i'm going to brush my
teeth but tom and jenny get so feisty
she don't want it right well we're
drinking
and [ __ ] you know i don't know i
[ __ ]
testosterone therapy it it it's gotta be
you guys
i well like he's on test i'm on test i
just finished watching the first season
of handmaid's tale today so i'm a little
salty yeah
about dudes in general yeah he got
something she's taking this [ __ ] out on
me i don't have anything to do with that
[ __ ] i didn't see that no but i'm just
do that i'm just telling you that yeah
right but you're like yelling at me like
about driving to like i'm making it up
or something but i'm just kind of like
i'm just telling you what it is in
florida
yeah in florida i understand and
honestly it goes from county to county i
grew up in volusia county um but i
didn't take my final driving test there
like i took what happened with me
was that because my birthday
is at the end of september
like when the school year started i was
always like too young to do stuff
because i was always like kind of like
what wasn't a year behind but i was
always like you know
you know when i started high school i
was like what 14 instead of 15 or
whatever age it was i was like a year
younger because my birthday didn't come
to like the end of september so what
happened was that
in 10th grade
uh zach says
thank you zach is it bad i'm 24 and
still don't drive yeah i actually
started no i didn't get a driver's
license until i was
25 26. like i got the permit when i was
15
um
and then i just i could never afford a
car so i didn't bother i just like
walked or took the bike i could
understand that that could happen if
you're in more
more of an urban type environment
but
me and granthars you know we were up in
michigan and it's kind of it's suburban
and then in mississippi oh mississippi
people were driving at 14
13 14 driving around
okay because you have to there's
everything's far apart it's all country
cops aren't going to bother you you your
dad went to school with those cops these
are little bitty places and you're
driving tractors
they're driving farm equipment
they're [ __ ] you know i mean there's
no difference
as long as they're not driving running
around drinking and driving you know uh
at that age and and if they're if it's a
local boy they'll let that slide
and it's just what happens in the
country is very different yeah it
depends on your circumstances because
some people that like live in a city
that don't like you know if you grew up
in new york city or somewhere like that
where you don't really need a car yeah
um then you know because i used to work
with a woman in the ass in a place yeah
it's like i used to work with a woman
who was from new york city she grew up
there and she didn't learn to drive
until she was in her 30s because she's
like i didn't need to i could either
walk or take the subway everywhere i
needed to go and it's just like you know
so i didn't bother
so you know in that situation i really
don't think there's anything wrong with
it you couldn't live in the south in
florida um everything is so far apart
everything is like suburbs we don't have
like this big downtown we don't have
very good public transport so it's kind
of like 15 minutes out that way it's
damn jungle yeah so honestly if you
don't have a car you're really
handicapped because i mean i grew up in
daytona beach which isn't a huge town
they had a bus system it's called votran
i don't know it's still called that like
volusia transport that's what it stood
for um but that was like so sucky that
you could only work
like the place where i worked for many
years i worked at a newspaper i
basically had to take i had to get up
like two hours before i had to be there
get ready get on the bus the bus ride
was like 45 minutes and then i had to
walk part of the way too because just
the routes were [ __ ] um it took
forever to get anywhere it's like you
really needed like an hour and a half to
get anywhere you wanted to go so after a
while you kind of if you didn't have a
car because i couldn't afford one for a
long time so you either like learn to
just like walk
i mean the house i bought a house
in 2002
2003 something like that um not too far
my grandmother's house so i could walk
to my grandmother's house if i needed to
go there i could walk to a grocery store
there was a grocery store there was
actually two grocery stores within about
a um you know about a mile there was a
con
not a convenience store but like a
walgreens type of thing
that was like within a mile so i can
actually walk and get my groceries um
there was a mall that was you could bike
there it was about five miles so i kind
of like
you know the house i lived in i was kind
of like it was kind of in a shitty
neighborhood but i was like at least i
can walk to a grocery store i could walk
to a walgreens i could walk to
you know i could take a bike to the mall
if i needed to
um because the bus was just you could
take the bus if you had to but it took
for
ever
it took like an hour to get anywhere
because everything was just so spread
out you know what i mean so finally
finally
i broke down and bought a car
and it had been so long since i took
driver's ed that i needed a refresher so
like i said i hired this lady like for
two weeks and i was just kind of like i
really need to learn to drive again
because i've been doing everything i
actually said it's the same in new
england because of all the farms kid
drives farm stuff yeah kids grow up
driving stuff
i grew up riding little [ __ ] honda
trail motorcycles some three three
wheelers
um
you know if i can all for every summer
in my life i was going to mississippi
and this being back in the 70s we had
these things called three-wheelers big
old three-wheeled motorcycle had one in
the front two in the back made by honda
and me and we were like 10 11
12 around that time
me and all the other boys
david and all the [ __ ] paul and brian
our dads all had those and we'd [ __ ]
just [ __ ] get on those things and
ride them around out in the [ __ ]
fields and [ __ ] wipe out wreck and
roll them and get hurt and
[ __ ] run them through [ __ ] ponds
and
yeah we'd run them into the pond and
then [ __ ] pull them back out that was
[ __ ] pain it was kind of an accident
somebody thought that maybe you could
run the thing if you were fast enough to
run it across the water
because it had those big ol
inflatable it didn't let it didn't work
uh yeah no it didn't work
because the front wheel doesn't drive
it probably would work if all three
wheels
spun
but nah
we hit that
it started with david david hit that
thing at about 45 miles an hour hit the
water
he went out about 30 or 40 feet but the
thing [ __ ] sunk
then we had to [ __ ] go in there and
[ __ ] tie a rope to it [ __ ] pull it
out with the other ones
it took forever to drain the water out
we thought we permanently [ __ ] that
thing up but it eventually fired back up
and we were riding around just [ __ ]
funny [ __ ] we were doing
yeah i'm just saying like if you grew up
somewhere where there was like good
public transportation it's because
honestly if i lived somewhere there's
good public transportation or [ __ ] was
walkable i wouldn't bother driving
either i wouldn't bother having a car
because having a car is kind of a pain
in the ass i don't really like having to
drive i don't like driving i don't
really like having to drive places um i
would rather just be able to like
walk or bike or no need for me too says
that [ __ ] you couldn't get a date in
his where he came up if you didn't have
a car no there's no way
no way you're [ __ ] you're backward
back
back when we were in high school
grandparents will [ __ ] back me up
where we were if you didn't have access
to to a car
over the weekend
you didn't have a license to [ __ ]
thrill you did not have a license to
thrill you were not gonna get
any dates no [ __ ] way
[ __ ] even the girls your age before
you could drive they wouldn't go out
with you unless you had a car they were
all [ __ ] dating older boys that had
[ __ ] access to those [ __ ] cars
so that was that was the way out of
boyhood and into manhood is to have that
[ __ ] car it was like a rite of
passage
well i kind of feel like even back in
the day like in daytona like i said a
lot of the girls had their own cars
but
they kind of wanted you know they kind
of wanted them to like the dude to have
a car too it's like you wanted somewhere
to like have sex you can't just you know
it was like a moving it was like a
moving hotel room and you could take it
to the drive-in well you had a park well
in daytona you had to park behind the
church he's taken to the drive-in
because the drive-in had closed by that
point
oh we parked that [ __ ] we'd go across
and go across the [ __ ] bridge and go
to go grow zeal grow zeal island and
[ __ ] park that [ __ ] down by the
[ __ ]
riverside and [ __ ] those those cars
would be bouncing out there
like five or six of them you have to
turn your lights off go in there
dark
there he is grabbed his nose we talking
about
says his first car was a mercury
ln7 it was a poon magnet i don't
remember that one
i don't remember that one
man my first car was a toyota tercel
yeah it was a five speed
i learned to drive a stick for that [ __ ]
grab this comes in the cemetery off
[ __ ] king road in jefferson i don't
remember we didn't go to that one i
never went to that one
i can't remember where that was what was
near there
i didn't i didn't i didn't ever i kind
of feel like back in my day like i said
the the drive-in had closed by the time
i was in high school i'm pretty sure
um so i kind of feel like people were
just kind of like they'd either go out
to tomoko state park
uh because there was a lot of like um
turn-offs on the road so people would go
out there even though it was like dark
as [ __ ] but that was cool because it was
like kind of spooky
or
they would go
um
one girl i grew up with it's like you
know
everybody would go kind of there was
this church that was like right around
the corner from her house
and uh it was in ormond beach it was
kind of in a nice area but they had this
big huge parking lot that kind of like
scrolled around the back so it's like if
you went around the back like to this
big ass parking lot like the cops that
were going by on nova road wouldn't see
you granted what was that what was the
name of that uh
that drive-in we were always tearing up
you you knew the name of it i forgot
what it was
that place was the [ __ ] teenage hotel
room that was the [ __ ] teenage public
open-air hotel room
it's hard to believe that that [ __ ]
actually happened i don't think anything
like that would happen today [ __ ] cop
surprise that [ __ ] would
if that [ __ ] was around today cops can't
be everywhere no this is what would
happen listen to me jenny what will
happen today is [ __ ] would pull their
phone out and start videotaping all that
[ __ ] that was actually going down and it
was [ __ ] would hit the internet and
people would be outraged and they'd send
[ __ ] swat teams down there to break
that [ __ ] up no they wouldn't
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] something else man
no one no one cares what four jokes
teenagers are doing they're [ __ ]
stars yeah they're going to send the
sword
this what team is going to come down
there that [ __ ] would end up
porn they'd have to put the [ __ ] end
of that it put it into that [ __ ] that's
really not how [ __ ] works but okay
that's how that [ __ ] would work in my
mind
yeah in in your mind that's pretty much
the only place
[Laughter]
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] pretty much the
only place like something out of the
damn movies
grant is telling man i'm not [ __ ]
lying man that [ __ ] no one thinks
you're lying george was the [ __ ] it was
off the [ __ ] chain man
i know you're it was awesome
yeah it was like
it was just another era
you're such a boomer it was another era
you're like not even a boomer but you
are a guy no i'm a gen xer but because
you're always like reliving no
i think i think what happened don't
listen to her
i think what happened i think what
happened was is the that [ __ ] was
happening like that because there were
no cell phones there was no way to
record anything
nowadays
i think those cell phones probably put a
damp would probably put a damper on
something like that now
people would be paranoid that somebody
would record it
and it would show up on the internet
i don't know you know i don't i don't
know if if if if drive-ins to that
extent are still going on well nobody
like drive-ins are a very niche yeah
thing nowadays not really it's not
really a thing i'm not saying that
people will still make out in cars and
have sex in cars uh they obviously do it
wasn't always inside the car well no i
know but i'm just okay
i know i've been on the top and i'm in
there i know i've been there i'm just
saying
that recently
um so you know what i mean
well you know before me and you got
together but you know still what you're
talking about like last week still no no
it's still fair because i wasn't there
fairly recently [ __ ] yeah okay i'm just
going to let you wonder yeah no i'm just
kidding it was uh before we got together
okay so you know so i so i know that's
going on but it's like i don't know i
don't know if people like
i think that people that have grown up
nowadays are just so used to
everything being recorded everything
being public it seems like it doesn't
bother them as much maybe i don't know i
feel like it doesn't bother them all
right ghost face kitty
are virgin daiquiris or pina coladas
manly or acceptable you're just asking
that okay
you should know about don't ask none of
that virgin [ __ ] is manly no
but the whole point of like having a
virgin drink is to make it look like you
have an alcoholic one well it's just
like so you don't feel weird around
you're like you know
maybe you were you're in a a and you're
like sober now and it's like you want to
hang out with your friends and like not
feel weird so it's like you want to have
a cocktail that looks like a cocktail
and it's like like i said i'm not
judging i'm not judging graham says we
would toss them at each other during
recess like little water balloons i
think he's talking about [ __ ] condoms
i guess
you're so like i don't know
i don't really like don't bring me into
this i'm not bringing you trying to
bring me into this [ __ ] hold on it's
almost time for me to put on a [ __ ]
wig i was gonna say it seems like man
we've we've been going for an hour and
40 minutes and like no wigs yeah no wigs
okay it's always good to start starting
that off with this one
is it i kind of like the mozart one
though
don't don't second-guess my wig choice
this one always gets me [ __ ] in the
mood
this one [ __ ] fires me up that's your
that's your michael kane
kind of wig there's something about
this wig takes me back to the 70s all
right when michael kane was still
drinking all right i don't know if he's
drinking as hard as he used to drink
wait is he dead now no i think he's
alive okay
i was gonna say if he's dead he's
probably not drinking at all michael
caine he he kind of straightened up to
become alfred in batman i think you know
oh that's true but he said see i thought
he died though i don't think he's dead i
don't think he's dead i'm not sure if
michael kane can die
he might be slightly
pickled
slightly immortal well see that's what i
keep hoping yeah that's what i keep
hoping where the hell's tila anyway tila
didn't show up today
i just realized she probably has better
[ __ ] to do
tila's a catfish account that's just
fake as [ __ ] it's gotta be
because she got a husband right
and if you look at the name tila that's
he-man's girlfriend's name
so i had to have forgotten is her
husband he-man
she would probably say yeah yeah we have
to see i had totally forgotten
because we re-watched like i said we
were re-watching uh the toys that made
us last night we didn't watch all of
them we just like watched select ones
and we watched the he-man one because
that was really entertaining
michael caine is still alive
oh okay yeah i thought he isn't that
weird i thought he died
they're asking what's the most manly wig
most manly wigs my [ __ ] black conan
wig
yeah i kind of feel like that's probably
probably
i mean because that's the one that looks
like you're in death clock especially
especially when i when my shirt's off
just just
shirtless with the one of these days
you'll get drunk enough to just take all
your clothes off
yeah just [ __ ] pick everything up
just drop my junk down on the little
[ __ ] table right here
put the camera on it or click freshly
shorter nuts and [ __ ] just [ __ ]
respectfully
just [ __ ] steaming on the [ __ ]
table see
zach's mouth is watering
is it oh god
yeah okay to see that zach i can't
[ __ ] show you that bro they'll
[ __ ] they'll [ __ ] take the channel
from me
from you
for me
it's just let me let me use this just to
turn just just it's just a turn of
speech you know that's just how i'm just
painting pictures with words you got
money i know i'm [ __ ] i'm just eating
pictures with words
sam sanders hadn't seen soapy forever so
sophie's she's been good good i talked
to her [ __ ] all the time on um you
know direct messages and [ __ ]
she's uh
working uh at
it's like a mail sorting place it's a
state job so she's working for her for
the state of michigan
and uh i think it's u.s post office
she's kind of subcontracted for him
and um
she's just kind of bummed out you know
[ __ ]
it's just personal [ __ ] you know i mean
she's like sick of the place wants to
get out here says
i said you can come visit us anytime you
want to and she goes man i want to but i
got to [ __ ] finish this job first
she's just [ __ ] always locked up in
the house and nothing to do that type of
deal
you know
and [ __ ]
she's always sucking worried about you
know like
her diet and working out and not feeling
all that good and i said she look man
it's looking
you need to get off all them [ __ ]
weird weird ass pills and birth control
pills [ __ ] all that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
with your hormones man eventually can
catch up with you
now that i know a little bit more about
the indracon system
i can understand how much damage of
birth control pills do to women
bad idea bad idea to [ __ ] with a woman
it's better to put the man on [ __ ]
test and have his nuts shut down
and then he and then that's a better
form of birth control because she he'll
actually get healthier
because he's got testosterone he's
injecting it
he'll even get bigger you know what i
mean [ __ ] healthier and he he'll
become temporarily sterilized
and you still have sex drive and
everything
they actually for some reason the
doctors when they started to [ __ ]
[ __ ] with this [ __ ]
they tried to stare temporarily
sterilize the women
that's a lot harder to do it's easier to
temporarily sterilize men they should
have went that way first yeah but you
know the reason they didn't do that was
because men don't like to be
inconvenienced about anything so it's
like much easier to just let's make the
women deal with this [ __ ] it might
have been the thinking might have been
it might have been more money into it it
could have been that see i don't think
it would have been another thing where
like well it's the women that have the
baby it was well it's the dude's making
the decision
so they're just kind of like well it's
not us
so we don't have a baby if they're the
ones that's having the babies we'll just
bomb all this [ __ ] up
i was thinking that earlier like i said
i'm a little salty because i was
watching like ham she's salty but i was
i was just kind of like
i don't think that most dudes like 95 of
dudes i don't think they could survive a
week as a woman i don't think they could
i really don't especially if you had
like [ __ ] had to deal with like
periods and like birth control and all
that kind of [ __ ] like all the [ __ ] that
we had to do you have to hormonally make
them women oh my god if you hormone you
hormonally make them women and they
would what what did the super chat say
thank you exactly zack says still not my
type tom sorry yeah see you got to put a
ring on it first [ __ ] trying to be hard
to hit you got to put a ring he's trying
to be hard to get
yeah that's never going to happen uh dom
the bomb thank you
jenny and tom thanks for being awesome
over the last couple years have a drink
on me thank you very much that that's a
tweet
in it no it's 9.99 nine pounds 99.
if it's over ten dollars between 10 or
20 i think it's a yellow i can't read it
from here i think it's yellow
he doesn't have his glasses on because
he didn't want to wear him because he
doesn't want to look
like nerdy on the ship no no that's not
nice i'm not looking nerdy no they're
not in here
are they no i had them i got them right
here
in my hand put them on your neck and put
them on put them on your damn face
look see this is how it is she tries she
tries to get in charge
see she tries to get in charge over
little things like that every single
thing like look we go out to the bar
uh-huh
i take my glasses
because i can't like i can see without
them but i can't i can't read anything i
can't look at my phone or anything like
that so i just kind of have use put him
on my head
he will not take glasses with him when
we go out
because he's oh well you have yours
yeah so it's like now people are like
trying to show them [ __ ] on the phone i
can't see that and i have to go
here
yeah
so this so does the wig make tom smarter
no no no
absolutely not absolutely not
says i'm trying to get man's nuts shut
down but he's not
what what what
what i'm reading a [ __ ] comment so am
i said seth says i'm trying to get my
man's nuts shut down but he's not so
happy with that idea
you have done it yet
that that's not the approach it's not
the baby shut your nuts down that's not
how you [ __ ] do it you say you say
ben go on test
go on testosterone you get bulked up
[ __ ] you'll be feeling good looking
good
um go work out some put out a few pounds
and just don't take
hcg or clomid and and because his
testosterone level in his bloodstream
will be high
the testicles will decide that well i
got enough in there i don't need to make
any they just kind of go on vacation
it's safe they've had dudes that have
been shut down for [ __ ] years yeah
nuts go on vacation sorry i just had
like a mental picture of two little
testicles like laying on some beach
chairs with margaritas yeah like [ __ ]
we got plants we don't need little feet
and arms yeah like we don't need to make
any more and we we don't need any
testosterone and when the test when the
nuts shut down it also shuts down sperm
production
so you will become temporarily
neutralized
they have some of those pro bodybuilders
that have been shut down for decades and
and
then they go back on something like
clomid or hcg which is a fertility drug
used in fertility treatment for women
who are postmenopausal you take that and
that'll [ __ ] wake those nuts right
back up and then a couple just a couple
weeks later [ __ ] they start [ __ ]
coming back and some of those dudes have
[ __ ] been shut down for so long their
nuts damn vanished back up into their
body gets so small like a raisin and
they go back in just like a going up
here where it's warm yeah yeah they go
up in there and it's just this empty
sack okay and they can be weird to have
like all your [ __ ] hanging out your body
all the time and they go up in there and
it'll and they can be up in there for a
long long time
without any problem so it's it is it
does act as like a temporary
vulnerable little
it is a term it is a temporary
castration i guess you could say you're
not having not castration wouldn't be a
good term temporary sterilization
um
you shoot total blanks nothing comes out
pew pew because it because i've done
that too i've just stopped taking
some of the other [ __ ] that i took shut
me down
and uh you know it's not an
inconvenience or anything it doesn't
make a difference you don't feel any it
doesn't feel any different
you can't [ __ ] spray out them [ __ ]
gorgeous showers and [ __ ] you know what
i mean it's not like that's not you're
gonna [ __ ] this sexy ass load it doesn't
happen but it's just you know what i
mean who's that sexy too though yeah to
me yeah like that's right [ __ ] he's a
pink that's right gotcha i'm just like
all right i gotta give you a shower
whatever
but you know
oh jimmy's like a hilarious perceive
things very differently yeah uh no i'm
sorry we have like a new we have a new
it's part of that yeah we have a new uh
chat person so there's a new chad no
we're a chat person yeah okay who is god
uh i was gonna say hello lily howell
hi youtube new here to the chat but i've
been a big fan of loyal listener for two
years
thanks to the conspira normal boys oh
okay yeah oh my god yeah we love that we
love those guys we've been on that show
like so many times yeah we always like
do their show whenever they ask you guys
are getting me through a really rough
patch right now
oh man that's like yeah
that gets me right here i mean i hope
you get through all the [ __ ] because
sandra said she doesn't trust men to
handle birth control he might love it a
lot no you know because if that dude
busts a nut nothing comes out then
you're safe
i don't trust him either i i don't know
oracle says oracle says the studies were
successful in terms of male birth
control working but the male
participants hated the side effects and
the side effects were about what women
put up with on the pill yep that's why
men wouldn't do it well it depends on
what what what was it that they used
what did they use they didn't use test
they didn't use anabolics like anavar
did they because [ __ ] dudes love that
well yeah but they probably gave them
some other [ __ ] up [ __ ] just give
them [ __ ] testosterone like the
[ __ ] [ __ ] up [ __ ] that we've
had yeah yeah you know right but you
know well see here's the thing no one
cares if stuff no no no no you're
reading too much
you read too much into it
it's real hard to get a patent on
testosterone
okay
these drug companies want a certain drug
that only they can sell
all right that they have a patent on so
they can make a bunch of money on it the
easiest one did my ponytail fall off
yeah my ponytail fell off yeah
you had a ponytail yeah i didn't know
you had that
it's the same color as my actual hair so
i'll just leave it off i don't care yeah
so they always want some kind of
patented special [ __ ] that only they can
sell you you know what i mean just just
[ __ ] take testosterone or good old
[ __ ] you know like i said nfl will do
that which is a very minor mod the thing
is is you can't run that all the time
you can run testosterone 24 7 for the
rest of your [ __ ] life and have no
[ __ ] problems as long as the dosage
is right you just don't
you just don't want to go
way up into the what they call super
physiological levels you know what i
mean where it's like six times what what
a man should have or even three times
four times what a man should have you
know then you start running into
long-term problems but it all just
depends on how old you are too like what
is long term
you know at 50 there
long term doesn't really matter anymore
you know i mean because
you know you you don't have enough
expect your life expectancy is long
enough to worry about that kind of [ __ ]
i mean if you've lived that long without
getting hit by a bus then you're like
really really lucky so you're lucky to
live in 80. so you don't have to really
worry you know beyond 50.
goat nut serum for real did you read
that [ __ ] book oh my god what was the
name of that book what was the name of
that dude we need to do a whole show
about that dude because there's like the
goat nut dude yes the goat nut dude well
not only did he do the goat nut thing
which um
uh spoiler alert didn't really work out
as uh he had hoped
um but also he was like super
instrumental in like starting
radio advertising like he like had the
money like to buy his own radio station
and all this other kind of stuff so he
was kind of like one of the guys that
like pioneered that kind of [ __ ] it's a
fascinating [ __ ] story
and it's like i read a book about it a
few years back and it was just like
really interesting so i i keep thinking
that like
yeah he um you know cut dude scrotes
open and put goat nuts in there um which
didn't it didn't really work out uh some
of the people died
and the people that didn't die didn't
really uh do anything so you know
can you imagine like how [ __ ]
desperate
you gotta be
yeah cut my scrotum and put some goat
nuts in there let's see if that works
out
i just i can't imagine
i can't imagine
being that
uh
being that desperate
i just can't
that you would just say i don't have a
screw but it's like if i did i i would
not want anyone cutting anything open
and putting
random alien things in there so you know
just saying
oracle mom says it was a combination of
testosterone and progesterone okay yeah
you don't need the progesterone
just testosterone we'll do it
but the fact that like dudes were just
bitching about that yeah about the side
effects of the [ __ ] i'm just kind of
like
[ __ ]
come into our world yeah for a second
and see how that feels yeah yeah
there is some merit to what jenny's
saying
um
i've dealt with a lot of guys who can't
can barely handle
even
the simplest
of drug protocols even just for for
health and longevity got there my dad
had a really hard time
just with the very basics in dealing
with his diabetes
there's something about certain kind of
guys that just well yeah i ain't going
yeah you know
i'd be okay you know what i mean in
general and they just don't [ __ ] [ __ ]
some guys are just very indisciplined in
general dudes are not real good about
they don't like going to the doctor
which i get i don't like it either
um they don't like going to the doctor
they don't like getting preventative
care yeah um they don't like and anytime
like they have to take honestly like
every dude i've ever known or like been
in a relationship with if they got sick
it was like the end of the [ __ ] world
they were like a giant baby about it
um
like honestly i don't know
so sometimes i wonder how a dude would
deal with like having a period every
month or every three weeks and in my
case because in my case it was every
three weeks um
i i just don't know if they'd be able to
deal with that yeah i really don't
because like honestly like every three
weeks like for a day or two like you
can't walk upright
and you just feel like you're gonna
throw up or
something like for no two days i just i
don't know if you guys could deal with
that like for that many years graham
asked me a question does is big dick
energy a learned trade or is it genetic
um it's genetic it's both it's a mixture
of but it's it's both it's both nature
and nurture uh
the salty cracker would know all more
about that but [ __ ]
dick energy is um
the chinese know it as
uh uh yang force or is yeah yang force i
think yeah yelling yeller yang it's the
positive side it's just it's it's
optimism
that's the idea
trying to get in some [ __ ] you know
that's the optimism part of it
but
i don't um i guess that's all i can say
about it
it can be it can
if you catch a person at the right time
at the right stages in life
you can you can kind of foster the
growth of that energy of yang energy
um and uh they can uh [ __ ] utilize it
better
um
after that so in other words like um
i don't know that's something that's
best
it's kind of like part of the young
man's game you know what i'm in [ __ ]
your late teens that's where you start
[ __ ] understanding the power of that
of optimism
because a lot of things you know there
have been dudes that have [ __ ]
made all these kind of self-help books
and everything and they've tried to
rationalize it
and make money on explaining how it how
it works
optimism is a very powerful thing the
mind is very powerful
um
a lot of stuff we were doing in the
military a lot of the dudes that did a
lot of great things physically were very
tired
and physically weak because they were
just worn down you know
through like long periods of exhaustion
and sleep deprivation but they did great
things on it and it was all just kind of
like
mental
willpower it's kind of like what
nietzsche would call
you know the will
and i really really very much believe in
it
george lucas and and and um
what's his name [ __ ]
his mentor
uh who's the dude that did uh [ __ ]
god of a thousand faces and um
joseph campbell joseph campbell that's
exactly he's from ucla he's a professor
in mythology
there's a certain truth in mythology
right
the [ __ ] the
they called it you know lucas called it
the force you know but it's i gotta pee
the chinese and the buddhists would
probably call it you know
yang energy
or you know but it's uh the mind is very
powerful the mind is uh the mind
is more powerful than the body in many
ways
it can give you almost a super human
levels of endurance
some of these people that have survived
[ __ ] situations that i can imagine it
you know what i mean but i don't know
how they did it like dudes that could
survive for a year at sea in a [ __ ]
emergency dingy you know trying to catch
fish with their hands and eating them
all with no fresh water and recycling
[ __ ]
[ __ ] bizarre and trying to capture
rain water
and just you know living off of a couple
drops of [ __ ] fresh water a day
and fish guts
[ __ ] man imagine that
but uh
mine is a powerful thing
see everybody
yeah no need for you to talk about the
hero's journey yeah
mythology always fascinating you know
they're talking about john carpenter and
dan
o'bannon and wendy uh
uh ucla yeah campbell every time i can
believe mythicism right
yeah dom the bomb says make sure that
everybody make sure to up thumbs up the
video thank you very much
thank you very much made me want to put
on an elvis wig well you have ones yeah
i know thank you very much people thank
you it might be time for me to put on
help it might be it might be all this
time you need a peanut butter banana
sandwich man i haven't had a [ __ ]
peanut butter sandwich in a long time
no meaning all right i'm trying thank
you very much people i'm trying to like
not eat
you know
[Laughter]
big kill to energy sure
i like a man and a kilt
i need i need to get
you should get i need to get a kill but
i'm going to get a kill from my
gladiator outfit yeah you need a
gladiator yeah gonna get like a roman
the roman kilt and [ __ ] shin guards
metal shin guards
and like a mermillo outfit
or a secutor or something with the
helmet and the [ __ ] gladius
wear that [ __ ] to the club
yeah you want to yeah
a little short buckler
shield
himself yeah
dj manager says i have five kilts oh see
you now
i don't know i like kill look at your
[ __ ] look at your hair
no it's okay baby
trying to get everything all
straightened up how soon how long would
i start singing like danzig and [ __ ]
actually this is my dancing wig this
would be elvis [ __ ] he'd be like well
you could be elvis there's a man in new
orleans he plays a rock and roll he's a
guitar
he's a great big soul
jumping like a catfish on a pole
it's like it's gone gone gone having
shaken king creole
like that
[Laughter]
camp guy says uh
they say the firefighter is the single
sexiest guy to many women
i like i don't know i don't
i don't know it's hard for me to say
across the board this makes sense this
is so hard
i know they even have like that
firefighter calendar and all that kind
of stuff i get it like i get that
they're like
manly mans are like super strong and
everything but also they will go in a
building and save a kitty which you know
we we all love that energy
um but i don't know it depends on the it
depends on the firefighter doesn't it
that's all i got to say
i don't know you so i don't i don't know
i think firefighters are universally
liked
well how can you not like somebody that
like saves you from a burning house yeah
i mean
it's hard to dislike somebody like that
yeah you know what i'm saying they don't
have all the baggage of cops
um who sometimes do questionable things
basically their whole job is to save
people from shitty situations you know
what i mean it's kind of like emts
i kind of feel like people can't dislike
emts either for the pretty much the same
reason
because it's like that's the if you're
in a shitty situation that's the person
you want to see oh thank god you're here
yeah i'm saying that i should wear this
wig when i go out and tell people it's
my natural hair
i mean no one will believe you because
everybody knows everybody
you still should though yeah
you got you got to come over
um there's a brush right there that's
like you got a comb over there mama
i'm for [ __ ] sake yeah
thank you very much do you see what i
have to put up i think
like you guys just you guys just see
this like a few hours a week like on the
live stream i have to put up with this
24 7. no she does she's up in here
hiding from most of the time yeah well
yes well she's got to work you know
where that is but yeah it's all serious
yeah like
i was thinking today i was like gosh i
work from
eight or nine in the morning until
usually six and the evening
every day seven days a week
well you're also watching movies and
[ __ ] yeah but a lot of yeah but a lot of
times like when we watch movies in the
evening
you don't have to do it you just do it
well i well you just do it you don't
it's better than a regular job but it's
still you do have to do it because it's
like i have to have like content so it's
like you want to like watch some [ __ ]
that you can like talk about do you ever
want to [ __ ] take a break you can
only just go in there and watch a movie
in there i don't care
i mean like i said i've been watching
i've been watching handmaid's tale
because
um well i wanted to watch it anyway
but i'm doing a it actually got pushed
back because everybody was like as
behind as i was so i didn't feel too bad
but we were supposed to like a big panel
discussion about it and they're gonna
record it like at the end of august and
like so many people were like holy [ __ ]
i've only seen like season one and it's
like i gotta catch up and i was like oh
my god i haven't even finished season
one so you know i don't feel so bad now
i finished season one
this morning
um like i'm literally like
exercising in my office and like
watching like the last episode and i was
just kind of like i at least have to
finish season one so i kind of feel like
i accomplished something there's like
three more seasons to go before the 22nd
like when they're gonna do it but like i
said it's just kind of like i don't i
don't know where it's gonna go now like
i said i read the book but
they um obviously they did a bunch of
different [ __ ] with it so we'll see how
it goes
damn tom homeboy can sing and then he
goes like an encore sing first and last
but always
so he knows that song and he now he goes
i'm drinking with you guys this is cool
yeah
he sings sisters of mercy in the car
like all the time
when it comes off i mean when it comes
on because like i said i have my radio
station which is i just have like the
generic goth radio yeah so they play
like a lot of sisters of mercy
so whenever that comes on he'll sing it
he sings sister to mercy
he sings uh
some older [ __ ] you can sing like roy
orbison and yeah you can do that yeah
yeah
i'm coming back one day
come with me on blue by you see there
you go yeah
with the fishing boats and the sails
will float on blue by you yes yeah
everybody [ __ ]
that's a good i love you representatives
he was like a candy-colored clown they
called us sandman
tiptoes in my room every night
and justice sprinkles stardust and he
whispers
go to sleep everything will be alright
i close my eyes
and drift away
into
the magic night what's next always
in dreams i walk with you
yeah yeah yeah every time you sing bruh
herbert it makes me feel like a moment
with david lynch
i talk
which is cool i'm not saying
in dreams you're mine all of the time in
dreams and
dreams boy
[Laughter]
i really i encouraged it yeah he's
encouraging it's just gonna happen uh
sandra says talking of work jenny you
should make an ad for the cookbook and
show it on the main shows yeah i did
think about that i just haven't got
around to it yet i think those shows
probably attract most of the new viewers
they do and they might not know about
the book yet uh jenny do you recommend
the handmaid's tale yes i do it's
awesome
but it's gonna bum you out and if you're
a woman it's gonna make you really
really really really mad
all right you're asking me if billy ida
was manly [ __ ] yeah yes for his age
group at the time
and then as he aged yes he did he was
you know i mean like he was a good
example of how i like billy idol he was
a good example of how you're supposed to
be in your 20s and and pretty good
example of in your 30s
and he's an old dude now but he's
pretty
he's kept himself together yeah that's
he's pretty good
and he also another thing that kind of
you gotta factor in with with billy
is that he's a junkie
that dude
not only is he
he's in and out of coke i think you know
probably away from that that dude is a
heroin addict
i mean he's got to be i mean he wasn't
he was young i don't know if he's still
out of it but he's always said that he
had serious drug problems
and
it's kind of rare that
a junkie can hold himself together for
that long
and um
but no he lived a good life
and
he had a good career now he can't write
that well all right he
a lot of his famous songs
that you know him by he had help writing
those
um
and
they bought a lot of songs too
and some songs
that were ended up being very popular
were written for him but he didn't buy
them like
um
that that song what was it the one that
simply read did
um
it wasn't simply red i thought it was um
i bought it
i thought it was um
what are the other [ __ ] called
there's a bunch of songs that other
people did
that were actually written for billy
idol i thought it was simple minds not
simple minds not simply read yeah what
was that called
uh don't don't you want me right no no
no don't don't you forget about me
don't you forget about the simple minds
one that was in birth
yeah that simple symbol mines bought
that but that was it that was made for
billy idol
and there well if you look on youtube
there are demos of billy
singing that yeah well now later on he
came back and did a single level oh okay
uh but he they
they made somebody wrote that for him
at the highlight at high times of his
career it was right after uh um i think
it was right after a rebel yell album
and he liked the song
but he thought it was a little too soft
that's a great song though so he passed
on it i mean
and simple minds bought it
um but then later on he would he he said
he regretted he regretted not buying
that song because that was a massive
this is a [ __ ] great so it's a great
song it's a great song just all around
right and then when you when you hear
billy singing it you go oh okay yeah
it makes a lot more sense when billy
idol's singing it
it sounds great
but you know yeah i'm not a huge fan of
simple minds but they did have like some
good songs like i said whether they
write them or not i'm not i don't really
know but
everybody wants to rule the world that
was a good song yeah remember that was
in the did you see the movie real genius
with val kilmer
did you see that movie
no
oh my god we need to do like a
retrospective on that because i feel
like a lot of people
that movie and my science project
i kind of feel like are two movies from
the 80s that i don't really see anybody
they're not horror movies but i don't
really see a lot of people talking about
them and i [ __ ] loved those movies
back in the day
they were on cable like all the time
yeah don bomb says he wrote dancing
myself rebel young yeah he wrote those
but you also have to understand that
that went through a quality control
process
people helped him with that
duran duran was the same way
um as duran duran got really big
they wrote some of that stuff but they
had a whole team of people and writers
to help polish that like look at the
demos for a thrill to a kill are you
gonna do
well that's a james bond theme yeah so
it's like obviously they're going to
have like cubby broccoli and all this
yeah yeah
and there was a lot of stuff that
you look up duran duran demos there's a
big difference between the demos and
what edit ended up being recorded
and it's because they worked on them and
they had a bunch of dudes [ __ ]
listening and goes that's not right it's
got to go like this oh you know what you
need you need you need more lyrics here
you need another verse here uh we gotta
do so it's
and then when those guys vanished then
you ended up with albums like big thing
which honestly i love duran duran yeah
um i bought big thing
i think that was the last album of
theirs that i bought so today i liked it
but i didn't like it enough to like buy
more after that
and then he ended up with [ __ ] like
medazard land
which had a couple of good songs on it
electric barbarella was great on it yeah
that's a good that's a good thing but a
lot of the other stuff was it was good
it was just that it was not that same up
dread ran pop standard
it was it had changed a lot
really duran duran's best album if you
ask me was notorious i don't know i
don't think jenny agrees with me but i
like to know i'm gonna say rio but
notorious was good too honestly i didn't
like notorious as much when it came out
because i bought it on vinyl back in
uh you know as soon as it came out and i
liked it but i didn't love it as much as
rio as much as the first one as much as
seven of the ragged tiger um i like it
more now that i'm older yeah but i still
like rio the best sorry notorious came
out in my senior year of high school
when i was in brazil sao paulo brazil at
the time
and i was just [ __ ] rocking man
everything was just [ __ ] banging on
all cylinders life was easy
i had money and it was just i was
in brazil at that time i was way old
enough to [ __ ] hit clubs
which most american kids back in the
united states couldn't go to a club but
no it's clubs and women and [ __ ] just
those lyrics and [ __ ] it was just it
was [ __ ] great it it basically kind
of
was the soundtrack to all the [ __ ]
partying and [ __ ] i was doing the year
before i joined the army
actually about a year and a half later i
ended up joining the rv but
when i graduated but it was just great
you know what i mean
at that time sao paulo was like a duran
duran video for me
from my point of view it was like living
in a duran duran video
geriatric punk says is pornography the
best cure album yeah yes yeah
all of them are good but pornography is
my favorite i don't know if it's like
the best one the top's great uh yeah the
top is also good i like the top because
it's like really diverse
there's a bunch of different styles on
it i like that i didn't like it as much
at the time because i bought it when it
came out in 85. faith was good uh yeah
like well all of their like kind of like
goth trilogy you know i love all their
early [ __ ] i even like their really
early like kind of more punk [ __ ] do you
like hat full of holo by the smiths yes
i do um it has handsome devil on it
which honestly
is one of my favorite smith songs of all
time i love handsome smith and all
morrissey is good
you know
i mean although i haven't got any
morrissey after uh
ringleader of the tormentors was like i
think the last one of his that i bought
but i've liked most of his solo stuff
there was another band that was kind of
like the smiths in there in the 80s that
i used to listen to i haven't heard in a
long time i'm going to go back to it it
was called the house martins yeah house
barns well they're from like the same
area well there was like there was the
house martens there was the wooden tops
yeah there was because there was like a
whole different thing i think people
like if you didn't grow up in the 80s
yeah there was this whole thing where
you had like your
synth pop if you want to call it that
would or like your new wave which was
all kind of like your depeche modes your
cure your that kind of stuff well like
you know bands with synthesizers and
then you had your bands that were like
the smiths that were kind of like a
throwback to old 60s
british pop mainly
um so you had that whole different and
it's weird because i kind of feel like
the bands were sort of like at odds with
one another even though in the u.s we
didn't give a [ __ ] we were just like
listening to all of it you know what i'm
saying because i was like listening to
like synth pop
from the 80s like all of the cynthia
stuff like new order and all that stuff
and then i was also listening to the
smiths even though i think that it i
don't know it i i feel like it mattered
more to them than to us
but i like a lot of that early
manchester [ __ ] like i said like the
smiths joy division i love the fall uh
you don't really hear a lot of people
talking about them anymore and like mark
e smith has passed away sadly he passed
away a year or two ago um but
but i love all that i love all that [ __ ]
down the bomb said i was talking about
is the producers yeah the pieces during
the production and the producers
the producers for billy idol and duran
duran when they were when they were
[ __ ] spot on when they were top of
the charts they got the best production
available which really made a difference
once that once they were no longer
popular they couldn't quite afford all
that support
it changed it's not like they were bad
bands it's just that
they weren't producing [ __ ] super
top-notch pop music anymore because
that's what that wasn't in vogue so they
had to kind of do kind of almost like
underground club music
and do things for like fans which it was
good but just wasn't quite as catchy
and uh billy idol actually
last really good album was whiplash
smile no no no excuse me
charm life was really good too
cyberpunk was good
but it started to go down after that
you know what i mean he he needs a good
team behind him but he's still really
idle you don't go to see billy idol here
listen to his
new stuff you go to see billy i don't
listen to his old stuff he knows that
which honestly i was kind of wondered
about that because i do kind of feel
like lately there's been a thing because
i know there's like a big 80s revival
and everybody's like into the 80s
because [ __ ] man we go to like 80s
nights and there's like [ __ ] 20 year
olds there and they're all like into it
and
so now it's like all these 80s bands
that had a couple hits back then are
like reforming and like doing these like
powerhouse tours and like people are
seeing it it's just like i just i wonder
how i would feel about it like if i was
in a band
what okay let's let's say that i was in
omd for
just for argument's sake even though
that was only two dudes in that band but
let's say i was in omd and it's like i
had a few hits back into you know if you
leave and like enola gay and whatever
and uh so then like i don't really have
any hits after that and then now
20 30 years later i'm going on tour
and i'm old and fat now and it's just
kind of like everybody just wants to
hear songs that i played like 40 years
ago how would i feel about that i don't
know i'm not really sure it's like i can
see how it would be really annoying
but
in a way they have to like appreciate
because tons of bands like struggle and
struggle and never get anywhere yeah so
it's like the fact that you had like a
couple of hits and people still remember
you this
many decades later i mean that's gotta
be
that's gonna mean something right so
mango says the smiths are so overrated
in my view i don't believe so bro
honestly i love this mess no morrissey's
a douche but i really i've always loved
the smith since i was a kid well he's
got to be who he is and he's always been
that way yeah he's always been kind of a
dude
he's a [ __ ] all right but he's [ __ ]
funny too um and but
this no the smiths were great you're
just not seeing it because you know i
know you're you're you're in england so
maybe you're prejudiced towards it
um you know because like even jesus
could not be a [ __ ] messiah in his
own hometown
um
[ __ ] uh morrissey is a master
lyricist a master lyricist beyond any
shadow of a doubt
and that's really was the smith's and
the more and morris's claim to fame
those lyrics
it's not so much the music even though
the music's great
it's the message and the and the lyrics
that although the music helped i'm going
to give credit to johnny
the only mastery that you see there
really is is lyrics he was a lyrical
master
um
and you kind of have to be a [ __ ] to be
a lyrical master because he [ __ ]
was snide you know what i mean and he
was playing all these games he's kind of
an oscar wilde type dude you know well
that was like his hero oscar wilde and
james dean were like [ __ ]
and it it was what it was but the thing
is is there a lot of lyrical
masters like uh
lemmy kilmister from motorhead was a
lyrical master
you probably wouldn't know because it's
hard to understand what he's saying
unless you know you know you know the
lyrics he was great very good
died recently well i guess it's coming a
couple years back yeah that was a while
ago about three or four years ago
four or five maybe but uh no i was a big
fan of [ __ ] lemmy too very cool
dj maniac says i picture you being into
moev more than omd i can like both
things i like both things
um things aren't as exclusive yeah i
mean i kind of like
i like everything my uh radio station
that i have on my phone my streaming on
my phone
is everything from
[ __ ] uh the misfits and the
undertones
and the stooges i have like old punk
[ __ ] like a minor threat
i have all that kind of [ __ ] then i have
like some 90s punk like bad religion and
[ __ ] like that and then i have a bunch
of 80s new wave
i have a bunch of 80s goth i have a
bunch of
80s indy like i'm super into like the
teardrop explodes and like lloyd cole
and the commotions and it's like i love
all that kind of stuff
and then there's like some 90s goth in
there
there's some like 2000s like kind of
dark wave indie rock type of stuff so
it's just kind of like i don't know i i
like all kind of different oh when i
really i also have like a bunch of old
uh
i have like johnny cash and like hank
williams a bunch of that kind of [ __ ] i
have a bunch of leonard cohen a bunch of
that in there so you know mango badger
said he also wasn't too much in a joy
division that's another one where you're
wrong
you're wrong
the thing which i love the thing the
thing with joy division
is that um oh boy i forgot his name
what's his ian curtis ian curtis his you
have to understand
go get that [ __ ] closer album
and listen to that
and listen to those lyrics
this sounds like a wise and
world weary old man of [ __ ] 50 saying
this [ __ ]
where are the young men the weight on
their shoulders
where are the young men where can they
be
where can they be
he's like what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] man
that dude sounds all tired he's
21 years old he was 23 when he had
21 years old he's reading right
yeah [ __ ] it's just like god damn you
know
and he sounds like a miserable old
chromagen he does it
he sounded like that from when he was a
kid which is hilarious this is some
arthur in a [ __ ] up kind of way arthur
schopenhauer pessimism [ __ ] going on
yeah he was super like i get it though i
got it
and honestly closer geriatric punk says
did joy division have only one album
they actually had two full-length ones
uh unknown pleasures was their first one
and then closer was the one that and it
came out like a little bit after ian
curtis died they also had a um
an ep which was i think was called an
ideal for living
and then they did substance which came
out uh
significantly after he died was kind of
like a compilation of stuff that hadn't
been like released megan says i i i've
heard it and it was pants he thought
that
go ahead and unsub go ahead i love that
album actually like closer is my
favorite um sensory deprivation yeah
album it's just one of those albums that
it just makes me think of like
wintry
days yeah and i love that feeling
because i live in florida and we don't
ever get that in real life dom's asking
me about um new order yeah they were
good too i love newark i love joy
division more yeah but new order awesome
also and um
look man maybe it's just not your thing
maybe i don't know how old you were
maybe maybe you weren't there
to have the context it was the beginning
i guess what maybe what you would call i
don't know cold wave it was very similar
to goth
um
if you listen to
sisters of mercy first and last and
always there's a lot of joy division in
that it's just the kind of a dressed up
prettier version i want to say prettier
there's more guitars in it there's a
little bit more music in it in
early
citrus of mercy but
it's that same kind of cold vibe
that
joy division had
and if it's just not for you it's not
for you but and yeah it was kind of
primitive and crude but that's what it
was that's
i like it i just like that whole vibe
i like the whole vibe like i said i like
any music that makes me feel like i'm in
a dead forest yeah in the middle of
winter yeah there's like no one else
around
like i love that whole vibe i'd be
driving around in boston snow everywhere
in the [ __ ] winter and [ __ ] [ __ ]
doing sales and [ __ ] [ __ ] in between
sales and [ __ ] joy division going and
that [ __ ] [ __ ] just it's just yes see
i love anything that evokes that i'm
gonna jump right on everybody's jumping
out of the stream because we're talking
about bands that they don't know
i only got 27 in the stream now yeah
[ __ ] you y'all get out of here if you
don't know we're talking about learn
it's all right it's where the music was
it's all right hold on [ __ ] this [ __ ]
oh he's done with oh he's gonna throw it
he's gonna i have to get i have to get
artistic you have to get artistic yeah
that [ __ ] was 250s right there
oh we're coming up into the 80s now yeah
i'm becoming like like a french like a
french [ __ ]
auteur
okay
you need a beret like i said i've told
you this before i'm gonna buy you a
beret for christmas i feel like
do manly men wear wigs [ __ ] right man
they do whatever they want to do they
don't give a [ __ ] well see that's what
i'm saying well that's kind of the
entire point i was trying to make on
this whole stream yeah was that
manly man
doesn't worry about what his family
manly man did he just does to you what's
manly and it's like
deal with it yeah
that's right i'm just gonna [ __ ]
dictate it i could wear it
hold your hand
there you go it's like i'm gonna wear a
sparkly eyeshadow and drink a big old
drink with a [ __ ] umbrella in it and
it's manly well we were watching with it
we were watching we were watching that
just do that clips of [ __ ] old
[ __ ] wrestling and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
some of those wrestlers were [ __ ]
like [ __ ] ready macho man savage they
were [ __ ] wearing all kinds of
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] that well i couldn't
on its own
that was manly but they were [ __ ]
getting out i feel like
metal thing
went to the wrestling was hilarious to
me because it's like well one it was
kind of like a repeat of like what the
new york dolls were doing like in the
early 70s
we're gonna like wear
all our girlfriends clothes and shoes
and makeup and stuff and yet still it's
manly but like i said they were doing
that in the 80s and i was totally about
that because i don't know
i mean if you grew up in the 80s like in
the early era of mtv like all the dudes
like they were in new wave bands it's
like they kind of like they were wearing
makeup and they had fabulous hair and
fabulous clothes and like girls like
love that [ __ ] you know what i mean it's
like we didn't care if it was manly or
not i don't give a [ __ ] it's like we
loved it it was awesome
uh lilly howell says clan of zymox is my
sensory deprivation band they are
actually playing here in where outside
of orlando in case you don't know uh
they're playing here in
february or march of next year because i
just did the poster for them tom has
seen them here in orlando i've never got
to see them unfortunately because i
really like clan of zymox but uh they
played here at uh independent bar which
is now called barbarella which used to
be called barbarell it's a big long
story uh but he saw them a few years
back and he said they were like really
awesome but yeah they're playing here
sometime in the next
somebody uh yeah
somebody's saying about clean design box
oh awesome uh actually they're they're
um i said they're under bars just trying
to get them to come back they are coming
here they're coming back i did the
posters did the poster already okay yeah
jenny did the poster for the for the
[ __ ] show it's in march march okay
uh [ __ ] man no i can't remember it's
somewhere here all right
i gotta lose i do
we're gonna get our asses on the [ __ ]
guest list i mean we'll have to ask mark
but your staff your staff and i'm staff
staff that's a staff but but we're
always trying to like schedule yeah well
well because i do like a lot of posters
for shows and stuff so it's like a lot
of times i get them free but you know
what i mean yeah she did a show for f
she did a a poster for mannequins
i saw that [ __ ] up on the wall and i was
like oh
man it's just and this is we need a copy
of that [ __ ] poster i want to hang
that [ __ ] i save all the [ __ ] which one
and it says what did it say underneath
it
uh it says black friday black friday
yeah and it says
i want that [ __ ] framed yeah i did that
one i did
i did uh i do posters for mannequins all
the time yeah i did one for
friday the 13th which is for this august
it's friday the 13th so i did a friday
13th one with like a black cat and a
broken mirror with a skull and it [ __ ]
and then i did one for
they're having a mad hatter party
yeah uh
sometime this month i can't remember
when it was the 21st maybe
and uh so i was really proud of how that
one came out i spent a long time like
[ __ ] around with that one but yeah i
really really like doing
i love doing like theme nights
so like i said the one i did for like
the blood bath i had a really good time
doing that one yeah anytime i can do
you know like you know they do pay me
for them but it's like i have a good
time doing them you know what i mean and
because i love doing [ __ ] on like themes
you're talking about um
susie and the banshees uh yeah you don't
want to forget the creatures though
there was a lot of good creatures stuff
that yeah the creatures were good too
yeah
so using the banshees probably my
favorite oh [ __ ] man now i'm trying to
think of like what my favorite album of
theirs was juju probably
but
susie yeah what was the one that had
what i liked tinderbox remember that oh
that was good too
oh
it's hard to pick yeah i kind of feel
like one of these days because i think
somebody asked me a long time ago like
pick your top favorite album top 10
favorite albums it's like it was it was
too hard i couldn't do it
i couldn't do it like if you're going to
go to like a desert island and you can
only take 10 albums with you oh [ __ ]
what were the time that you would want
to move would be kiss me kiss me kiss me
man the other one would be pink floyd's
[ __ ] metal remember medley yeah metal
yeah had echoes on it
man that would be hard you can [ __ ]
just chill out to echoes there's a whole
side of an album and [ __ ]
same as as my dog was
you
outside
[ __ ] some
you can bust on prog rock
and probably no some of it's good though
yeah doesn't say but
self-indulgence but you know
[ __ ] some a lot of that pink float is
[ __ ] the masterpiece i like pink
floyd yeah really good um
i like a lot of that [ __ ] from back
though i like floyd i like the doors
yeah that wasn't prog rock though well
no i know i'm just saying doors was
almost proto goth it was yeah
it was i think that was one of the
influences but so was so were the stones
i mean you know what i was thinking
about
probably uh some of the stones was
[ __ ] really hard the early stuff yeah
this morning or
the other day because i was like listen
to my radio when i was out
doing my power walk and dolly's car came
on which if you don't know was after
peter murphy after bauhaus broke up
peter murphy
had a little band called dolly's car
with mick karn who was in the band japan
they only released one album it was kind
of an ep it was seven songs on it it was
called the waking hour and it was really
good it came out 1985 and it was kind of
like
but it was very proud rocky and then i
was thinking to myself that arcadia yeah
you know the three dudes from like simon
nick and roger from during iran
released uh sir read the rose the
arcadia album also in 1985 which is also
very prog rocky so i kind of feel like
in the mid 80s there was kind of like a
prague rock a little bit of like a mini
revival of pride in the mid 80s dom is
asking me about the first two albums
from iron maiden
i don't know what the question is
maybe maybe he's asking me
if i like just to comment on them yeah
paul diana was the [ __ ] [ __ ] all
right i really liked the first two i
liked both vocalists paul was great
um so was bruce
um they were almost like two different
bands though
iron maiden and killers was almost kind
of like a power metal punk
thing
it had it was
it had a 70s hotness to it a heat but it
also had kind of like a punk rock
threat kind of vibe to it very kind of
like street level
um i liked the [ __ ] topics of the
songs
um paul [ __ ] sounded great
the first album too you know [ __ ]
what was that
unchained tomorrow what was
before my eyes was the name of that
[ __ ] song
something or other tomorrow and then
there
it was just that yeah they were [ __ ]
great albums man
and then when killers came out the band
was extremely tight
that was a [ __ ] great album
um
yeah
but you know he they they were not
comfortable with touring with him he had
a [ __ ] drug a drug problem
so they got bruce
and evidently you know
some of the people were not happy with
bruce bruce wasn't really they didn't
think that he fit in with that band he'd
come from another bed i think it might
have been lionheart i think is what the
name of it was it was just
and
that
he had bruce kind of had like a fufu
image at that time
on the street you know what i mean
you're so fufu yeah
you know what i mean
so if when they hired and they said you
go right out right now and go buy you a
leather jacket [ __ ] get out get take
that [ __ ] off get your leather what is
this get you some [ __ ] skinny jeans
skinny jeans and a leather jacket man
get that [ __ ] [ __ ] off there
because he was expecting
he was
he was kind of proud rocky a little bit
you know
and uh
but no [ __ ] uh
bruce was great man bruce brought that
band into greatness and i like bruce i
like bruce as a man he was an achiever
and he's a he and he's a he's a fellow
short guy so you know
it's gonna be in a short man of mafia
you know he he uh but he was
he and he's evidently a great pilot
[ __ ] couldn't [ __ ] fly a
whole airliner
but uh how many of y'all can yeah uh
what was really great about iron maiden
is that in the united states it was kind
of stereotypical to think of metal bands
as [ __ ] dumbasses because
bands like
bands like molly crew were those these
are [ __ ] dumbass this is okay well
yeah and like a lot of their fans you
had to admit were kind of like right
meat heads you were kind of like
meathead [ __ ]
but uh
iron maiden were
were smart guys they were very smart
intelligent guys um and
they uh they didn't play the meathead
game they were pretty intellectual and i
like the fact that they stood up for
england they were very patriotic about
england which i i admire patriotism in
anyone people should be proud of where
they come from and their cultures um
and i just i just liked them i liked
them [ __ ]
honestly i never had a beef with
like
older metal bands um i didn't like like
the whole like 80s
metal thing
because i don't know like i said it just
seemed like to attract a bunch of
dumbass people which it all depended on
the bands and how you were appreciating
it and what you were going to do now was
was iron maiden better
better than judas priest
well see i don't know
that to me just seems like they both
seem like equally good at times iron
maiden was better
but i i think judas priest overall might
have been a better band it was a little
bit more it was a little more varied in
what it did
um
i think it was a little more innovative
it was around first
um
they had a lot more material they didn't
really kind of stereotype themselves
iron maiden towards the end of the time
came out with some albums that were
pretty [ __ ] bad
especially in the 90s and 2000s
but you know what i mean it was changing
members and stuff
man it's hard to say
david june asks is rush manly no no no
but they're good though you can like
them if you want they're good but no i'm
not a fan but uh
you know but i'm not going to [ __ ] on
people that are a fan because they're a
good band i recognize that it's just
it's not for me yeah um
lily asks you guys like switchblade
symphony yeah yes i actually really like
switching i have all that actually back
there i have in my cd pile i hung out i
hung out with
two or three of their albums i hung out
with tina tina root tina yeah at uh at
man race in boston when they when they
[ __ ] toured and i saw an interview
with her from back in those days it was
like a couple months after that happened
they asked her what the best club was
and she said man raised in boston was
great those people were great and that
was [ __ ] i was like thinking oh she's
talking about me
probably not though
you're so vague but uh yeah
they were good live but it wasn't
destined
to last evidently that band didn't make
much money and it was poised to do
something in the end which is a shame
because they were really good bands yeah
that band could have gone
actually mainstream they probably just
got sick of it i think they did and but
had they stuck it out a little bit
longer maybe they would have made some
maybe they just they broke up they they
didn't officially break up forever it's
like kind of like they took a hiatus and
never came back
tina's now a last i heard a uh
a real estate agent
the other girl last i heard and i forgot
what her name was
uh
some of you might
the other girl last i heard she was a
massage therapist whatever that means
because man they [ __ ] i feel like
i don't [ __ ] know but yikes
let's not let's not say that but like
i but i mean in the 90s
they were kind of like one of the big
yeah that was something like all the
gods in the 90s were listening to
i mean that's a like i said that's a
little
past my time because i'm like more an
80s girl but it's like i was into the
90s [ __ ]
and i really really like switchback
switchblade symphony but
you know i kind of feel like everyone
was listening to that i'm so i was going
to clubs in the early 2000s and they
were still playing a lot of their [ __ ]
so
you know and it's kind of a shame that
they didn't get as
popular or famous as i feel like they
probably should have
you know it always like bums me out when
i hear about bands that i really liked
and then like 10 20 years later it's
like yeah i had to get like a regular
job
and now i'm like right that like always
bumps me out yeah dj maniac said that
iron maiden they're not exactly
brilliant lyrics either no
no the the thing about iron maiden is
that
you can go back
to numbers of the beast or
peace of mind you can go back to those
two albums and even power slave which
some people say is their best album
you can go back and those are some
pretty superficial almost kind of like a
teenager [ __ ] writing a damn
story about something he studied the the
[ __ ] are watching movies
they're watching movies and making them
make a song about it
or reading it like the misfits and [ __ ]
did that too yeah no and the misfits
were admittedly a lot more remarkable
i'd have to say that
the first two
paul diano albums
had a lot better lyrics they were more
organic
it was kind of like something that you
could tell they were more artistic kind
of like something that was kind of made
up on the spot twilight zone oh that's a
[ __ ] great song
yeah about a dude [ __ ] who's died
he's on the other side of [ __ ] in a
parallel dimension watching his
ex-girlfriend saying i'm gonna come get
you
where you know i miss you you're gonna
come over here to the other side and
join me and check this [ __ ] that's some
[ __ ] creepy [ __ ] even even the family
of the op i think family opera was just
[ __ ]
i mean i like that song but i think that
was just an instrumental there was a no
that wasn't they had lyrics i remember
yeah the fan of the opera uh song was
pretty good
the first two albums i think had better
lyrics they were more organic
yeah
but when it comes to lyrics if you're
going to talk about lyrics and metal
judas priest had [ __ ] fantastic
lyrics
especially the lyrics off that sin after
sin album that that was my favorite
album
you know the 70s 70s jesus priest
some people would say well british steel
yeah that's that album sounded great but
artistically man
sin after sin was about and sad wings of
destiny those are their two best albums
um
and screaming for veggies of course that
was a [ __ ] great album too
even though i like defenders of the
faith that was [ __ ] good i remember
when that came out
i
came out when i was in brazil i'd be a
[ __ ] teenager playing hooky from
school staying up in my [ __ ]
apartment [ __ ] drinking listening to
the [ __ ] defenders of the faith
waiting for my mom to come home
i can have some weird [ __ ]
i did that too but i was listening to
like joy division and alien sex sweet
about how uh geriatric punk says you
guys should do album reviews like the
movie respect we have that's a good idea
we've actually thought about doing like
music because honestly
man
i was thinking about it earlier because
i thought the question that i asked
myself
uh if you had a legit like take 10
albums like to a desert island because
you know that's like your desert island
kind of [ __ ]
i don't think i could pick because
honestly if you just made me pick
one just one for an example if you just
maybe pick one nick cave album
i couldn't pick
sorry
because some days
um you know let loving is my favorite
some days
firstborn is dead is my favorite
some days
a different one is my like your funeral
my trial is my favorite so it's like i
don't i don't know if i get paid uh so
somebody's asking mr robotto is asking
jenny are there no goth jobs
like working at hot topic for example no
um
honestly okay jobs are in clubs
if you are lucky enough so i was lucky
enough um because when i was younger and
i looked like a weirdo and everybody
told me don't get tattoos don't shave
your head don't get piercings in weird
places blah blah blah because you won't
be able to get a job
but i was like [ __ ] you i'm gonna do it
anyway
but i went to school for graphic design
and it turns out that
some places not all places
if you're
a graphic designer if you're an artistic
person you get a little bit more leeway
so i was able to get some kind of
corporate jobs
uh you know at newspaper public
publishing companies that kind of places
and everybody just thought it was kind
of cute that you look like that because
like oh you're the already graphic
design person okay
so it's like so i kind of got away with
[ __ ] because i was good at what i did
so i didn't have too much trouble
finding jobs
but i know other people did back in the
old days it's probably easier now um
it's yeah i know they'd be [ __ ]
starving i know it's easier now
back in the i was just lucky i was lucky
uh i covered my tattoos up like i put
down my hair so they couldn't see that
it was shaved like you know i tried to
look as normal as possible which
you know let's be honest isn't all that
normal
but
i was able to get away with it for a
long time and i was able to have kind of
cooperative jobs in publishing and stuff
but
i don't know but i did see like a lot of
like in the 90s
i started seeing people working at
hot topic stuff like that which like i
said is good
if that's what you want to do i'm not a
retail person
my first job was at a record store uh in
man
the early 90s
it was probably like 91 yeah it was 91.
i had a job at a record store in a mall
and
i looked as normal as i could look for
the [ __ ]
but i did not have a good time i'm not a
retail
i'm not a retail person and even though
it was like working in a record store
i'm not good at like pretending to be
like be nice to people that are stupid
jenny isn't fit for [ __ ] society i'm
not okay um i'm not yeah
now um i'm fully aware of that i've been
aware of that since i was like a
teenager so it's like not a big
revelation
yeah they're talking about i have a hard
time dealing with people
and like not
and like pretending that i don't hate
them you know what i'm saying yeah it's
like hard for me to like yeah um
metallica did have good lyrics uh
metallica's lyrics actually were better
than iron maiden's lyrics now iron
maiden did have some good lyrics
they weren't as good as metallica's
though
[ __ ] the the lyrics the lyric
what's his name steve
steve harris
you
he his lyrics
were focused upon a certain subject he
was very kind of like uh
um mission oriented with lyrics if he
was going to talk about a subject he
stick right on that subject it was hard
for them to mix a bunch of subjects
together they couldn't be artistic and
vague
um the closest they could get to
something like that would be like
oh [ __ ]
what was the one um
what was the one where uh focused on the
peace of mind album
it's about looking in the damn pool and
the dead people [ __ ] and uh
dead people going around it's called um
yeah the dead peoples were calling i'm
not a mental person you're right yeah
they're dead people down in the pool
calling you in
still life that was the name of that
they couldn't do a lot of songs like
that still life was a very good song
it had good lyrics it was a
a unique topic that they had i guess
made up
and it kind of had a lot of artistic
qualities to it
it had elements of being kind of like uh
uh abstract
and that was the that was the weakness
of
of bruce dickenson era iron maiden it
was literal it wasn't very abstract
i didn't know that at the time because
rock type music and hard music was
evolving
skinny puppy had not happened
when i listened to skinny puppy that's
when i realized what lyrics could be
that [ __ ] was abstract as [ __ ]
and i was like how the hell are they
writing this [ __ ]
i found out later how they wrote that
they would take a paragraph from from a
subject that they'd liked and then like
rearrange it and cut it up yeah
cut the [ __ ] sentences out well that
was kind of like a big thing and then
there was even like a poetry set that
had magnets yeah that had just like
words in your fridge yeah go half the
[ __ ] out throw it into a hat rearrange
it and what was left they tried to make
a song out of that
and that's how they did that yep and
they got you could get the point across
but it was in a very abstract form well
you could read your own [ __ ] into it
yeah which which instead of telling you
what was going on
it was a it was suggestion it was all
suggestion and your mind was filling in
the blanks
which in a way to me that's the most
successful because i think one of the
things that we could keep coming back to
this because we i love this documentary
the thing that was about anvil
the problem with anvil
if you guys don't know who were like
this band yeah and there's like a really
good documentary about them it's like
it's awesome and funny but also kind of
heartbreaking at the same time
their
thing was that they tried to be too
literal right and you see here's the
thing
if you listen to anvil and then you
listen to iron maiden
anvil is trying to do the exact same
they're talking about the same thing
they're talking about the same thing
they're trying to do the same thing iron
man does
it's just that they don't have the skill
that iron maiden has
and [ __ ] iron maiden was passable its
quality was good
but the same thing done by somebody
who's not quite as good it fails
epically
it's epic fail
but a band as bad
as anvil would have done a lot better
had they used
skinny puppy's lyrical
method of just cutting up a bunch of
sentences
and putting it together because like i
said people people would have read into
what andrew was saying people like a
little bit of mystery right if you're
writing a song right that says i'm
writing a song about this movie remember
this is
yeah very lame no one can like re i was
like oh okay we're talking about that
like there's no mystery anymore there's
no you can't you can't artistically
there's no space for you right yeah in
that right you have to like make it
you don't have to make it like so vague
that nobody knows what the [ __ ] you're
talking about but you have to make it
vague enough that people can like read
their own situation into it because i
kind of feel like that's what makes
people
resonate
with the piece of art whatever it is and
says lane can be cool well go listen to
something depends go listen to some
anvil and you tell me if that's cool
that's what and i felt so bad for them
because they really seemed to not
realize
what they were doing wrong
it was robotic and it was very robotic
i'm like don't just like watch a movie
it's not artistic
don't just like it worked for the
misfits i guess
but it's like don't just watch a movie
yeah and just like sing a song
describing what happened in a scene in
that movie
and then there was this thing and it did
this and it did that and it's just kind
of like that nobody wants to like listen
to that no
it's not artistic at all you can't like
read your
you can't
there's no room for you
no way to interpret anything right it's
telling you what it is right and it's
just kind of like i don't
you know what i mean i don't know it's
just it's this whole thing but um
mr roboto says jenny you could have
managed a goth band i probably i
probably should at some of these days
some of these uh yeah somebody said um
oh granthurst hammer says do gods ever
feel secret shame when they have to look
normal to work for the man yes
yes
i do not like and the thing about it
because
like i've said before i grew up my whole
life like not really sure if like what i
was doing like
uh i always
vaguely felt like i was doing something
wrong but i wasn't really sure what that
was
um you know what i mean because i'm not
really
i don't know what other people's deal is
so i'm just like you know so i'm just
like having problems navigating so it's
like when i had to like look for a job
like i was lucky because
i stumbled into a lot of situations and
i was in an artistic field so already
people are going to be more forgiving
but
you know i was lucky to stumble in a
situation like oh you looked witchy and
we like that so it's like you know you
can work here but it's like
i don't know like for a long time
it's like when i would go to look for
jobs
i would have to like okay so i would
have to like wear the okay i have to
wear my hair down i feel like do that i
can't wear like weird makeup like what
does normal makeup look like i don't
really know
and it's like so
i look at myself and be like is this
weird i don't is it i don't know so it's
like i couldn't really tell
and then sometimes i would go and i do
go to the interview and it would seem to
go fine but then later they wouldn't
call you and i'm like
did i look weird and then no it's like i
don't know i'd say i have no idea
um i never had any basis for comparison
like what
what normal was or like what weird was
so it's like i never really knew
if people were just not giving me a job
because i looked like a weirdo or if
they just like weren't giving me a job
because somebody else was more qualified
i don't know it's like it's a weird it's
a whole thing so it's like this is my
life at this point
uh lily says alien sex fiend that's why
i dig your hair gently
seriously i love alien sex pain i love
you only text being i love all of that
man i love all of that [ __ ] all that
[ __ ] specimen alien sexy all that like
[ __ ] bat cave stuff i love all that
i'm all into like the old
bat cave [ __ ]
all the old death rock [ __ ] i like a lot
of the new death rock [ __ ] too
uh or newer death rock [ __ ]
you know i say newer but it's like
early 2000s early to mid 2000s because i
feel like there was kind of like a death
rock revival you had like cinema strange
you had like bloody dead and sexy you
had like frank the baptist you have like
all that kind of [ __ ] i like all that
kind of [ __ ] too
but
i kind of wish that would come back
because
it's about time now been the cycle
when you get old it's everything seems
like it wasn't long ago but it was like
a long time ago
[Music]
all right so nick cave was my first
school girl crush when i was younger
man nick cave
is
my
favorite we've almost been on for three
hours that's okay okay
i [ __ ] love nick cave i love the
birthday party
i love
like all of that [ __ ] that has to do
with like early birthday party i love
all that [ __ ] i have all their albums i
have all the nick cave
albums and if somebody made me pick a
favorite
i honestly don't know if i could
honestly henry's dream is the one i
probably listen to the most
but
all of them are good honestly i went
through a period where i was listening
to nothing but
from her to eternity which was like his
first solo one
because that is like it's so sparse but
it's like so [ __ ] man it's like so
sparse and like a little bit amateurish
but it's like it's so [ __ ] good
they're saying i need a caron wig what
is a karen wig
you know what a karen wig you don't know
what karen is i know what a karin is but
i don't know what the wig looks you need
that uh i'm gonna i need to talk to your
manager haircut okay yeah which almost
kind of looks like a 90s like jennifer
aniston kind of haircut okay but updated
for the modern era
[Laughter]
it's that kind of
it's like an upper middle class entitled
white [ __ ] haircut
you need that kind of wig
[Laughter]
why does why does my like soy latte not
have soy
in it or
whatever i don't know i don't know what
karen's do
mr ross says tom's a metal metal guy do
you guys clash musically no i'm not a
metal guy i started off as a metal guy i
like metal
yeah it's like well the thing about it
is that we're not
um
i like some metal too yeah but the thing
about it is that
we don't really have i mean when i met
him he was like more to like goth and
new wave and stuff and then he's like oh
when i was a kid i liked metal and he's
like he still listens to a lot of that
but a lot of that stuff is good i like
that stuff yeah i'll only listen to
classic metal i go to 70s and 80s yeah
so it's like i like that too so it's
like i'm not bothered yeah or you know i
like some people were going on about
about metallica
[ __ ] i had the first [ __ ] metallic
album before anybody knew what it was
and
we were sitting there it ride the
lightning and seem to kill them all came
out you got a little yeah got a little
yeah kill them all came uh we're
watching
we were listening don't worry about it
no well yeah you don't got it though
it's this and she she got to fix you it
needs to go okay um kill them all came
out
and
we were we were going man this is a
great band
but it wasn't
it didn't stick out that much versus the
other bands that were around at that
time like we were listening to another
band was called yagpot yag ponther or
yagponzer i don't remember
and uh also we were listening to
merciful fate around that time early
immersed king diamond and merciful faith
and that was metallica was just another
one
another one of the new ones
and then the ride the lightning album
came out and we're like oh man this is
it this is the new sound and of course
iron maiden was putting out [ __ ] good
music too i think that's when powerslave
came out we liked that also
but when
when ryde the lightning came out we knew
we were dealing with like something
[ __ ] really serious that that was
going to change the game
because it made iron maidens sound very
tame
it sounded very tame compared to that
but you know
merciful fate
from that same time
sounded a lot [ __ ]
darker and weirder than um
than
the metallica did metallica was very
thrashy we liked it
but it wasn't very spooky
yeah it looks merciful fate kind of had
a real spooky sound to it kind of
ghostly
although i like that too yeah
we were listening to um
venom and slayer also although like
satanic black metal we like that too
see i was i was kind of had a soft
survivors layer yeah i gotta say but by
the time
86 rolled around i was more into goth
and girls
and there's something about you get laid
or something and then all of a sudden
you start you know
well i kind of like this you know it's
something hormonal it's kind of hormonal
shift you like the metal stuff but i
started to appreciate stuff like duran
duran and
bauhaus and sisters of mercy oh your
windows are perception
because i do kind of feel like people
that are like
you know when you're like the super
hardcore medal super hard with this and
that and the other it's like
that seems to be like a kind of like i
said like kind of a narrow window and
i'm not judging like because i know a
lot of people and i like a lot of that
[ __ ] but it's very narrow but it's like
when you get older you kind of like
learn to appreciate yeah you like that
still but it's like you can like lots of
other things with it i think i think
part i think one of the bands that
really kind of helped me
i think one of the bands that set me up
for goth and and and and new wave even
though i had been listening to new wave
on the radio before
i really got into metal but it kind of
brought me back to because you know
growing up in california we had kroq and
they were playing [ __ ] very early
dragon ran at adam and i like that too
um
but it didn't sound very tough you know
metal sounded very tough i liked that
later on
but i went back to the to other stuff
because you start going you know you
know things don't have to be [ __ ]
tough all the time come on open it up
that's what i mean we're going back to
the manly man thing
it seemed like it was a million years
but it was actually like only 18 months
two years yeah you know
but um
oh one of the bands that really kind of
[ __ ]
broadened my perspective this motorhead
motorhead album when he looked at a
motorhead album it was very impressive
it kind of had kind of like a [ __ ]
real tough kind of like a biker image to
it it was weird you know this big
[ __ ] angry pig with [ __ ] tusks and
[ __ ] blowing up you know like on the
iron fist album or
not iron fist [ __ ] [ __ ] overkill
or or something you know
and then you listen to it and it is
pretty hard but it's also slow and then
as you listen to it and get used to it
you also realize that what this is is
this is very hardened up blues
and the lyrics are really good
there's a there was an element of street
wisdom
to [ __ ] um
to lemmy's lyrics yeah and it was kind
of like
how
kind of like a dude who's sucking kind
of like who's gotten the shitty end of
the stick he's kind of a loser but
that's only superficial he's not a loser
he's a winner you just not right you
don't see that he's a winner he's
playing all these games with you you
know
like you know and
then
this is before the internet you don't
know who this is singing this there was
no access to them directly
later on in adult life you can go and
you can watch let me kill mr and [ __ ]
fast eddie clark and [ __ ] and and and
[ __ ] uh
phil taylor filthy animal tailor yeah
and and and you see the way they are
with each other and it's hilarious they
constantly drive [ __ ] lamy
and they just drive him and driving him
about stealing his girlfriends and doing
this and they just
and really only dudes who grow up
together can be that brutal to each
other and it's [ __ ] hilarious and it
kind of like puts all those lyrics in
the proper perspective of who it was
that was talking to you and um
i'm sad that he died you know but he did
leave a son behind in california he had
a
uh i guess i think he said he's an
american song wasn't german was no he's
american he's got an american son
and he didn't know that he was [ __ ]
let me had to tell him later i'm your
dad you know right
can you imagine yeah yeah i was like
you're my dad
yeah yeah i'm your dad if lemmy came to
me and said he was my dad i'd be like
for real she's like yeah me and your mom
used to hang out she didn't tell you but
i'm your dad you know that'd be so
awesome and he did get to know his son
they became friends and [ __ ] in their
adult life because the guy didn't know
who he was
but um
no i like i like to let me a lot and
[ __ ] um there was something about
that music
that opened me up to a bunch of other
[ __ ] that was like classics like the
doors and
[ __ ] uh
uh [ __ ] led zeppelin and the thing
about motorhead yeah is that
they're one of those bands
um you know motorhead like
the ramones i feel like it's very hard
to dislike
unless you're lame yeah
it's very hard to dislike motorhead it's
very hard to dislike the ramones it's
just kind of like
so if you get into it
it opens up this whole other thing
um like you said
you getting in a motorhead it opens up
this whole other thing to you it's like
i said they they're super into the blues
it's like what you know with the remotes
it'd be more like
getting to like
rockabilly
you know all that kind of [ __ ] because
punk rock is really just kind of speeded
up
rockabilly is what it is yeah nothing
wrong with that because i like a lot of
rockabilly too
um
[Music]
oscar says take a shot every time jenny
says like please please do not do that
no uh you will die of alcohol poisoning
so i mean if you want to do that that's
on you
uh geriatric punk says not old enough to
have seen the ramones live i never did
either
uh but super jealous
i've seen okay what's the oldest band
i've seen live
the cramps i've seen the cramps live i
saw bauhaus live
yeah i saw christian death live
um i'm trying to think of like the
oldest band okay dom corrected me his
son's english but he lives in california
yeah okay all right
yeah i agree dog [ __ ] motorhead with
[ __ ] phil taylor and fast eddie they
would be really good um one of the
[ __ ]
one of the most divisive albums
from motorhead is one of my favorite
favorites
and that was uh
another perfect day
they had kind of a guest guitarist for
that one i don't remember what his name
was they kicked him out after one
album because they just said he kept
washing his goddamn feet
and he was just too clean he kept
washing his feet and [ __ ] well at least
he's watching and he was just and he
kept showing up live to these shows just
wearing [ __ ] bermuda shorts and a
[ __ ] they didn't like how he looked
but he was a prague rock guitarist i
don't remember the guys and that
particular album had was [ __ ] great
another another perfect day and even
lemmy himself will say that that is a
great album but they just didn't like
that guitarist i don't remember what his
name was
and um
it was kind of an elevated
motorhead in the way that it sounded it
was good
i mean motorhead are awesome
i don't really think anyone will dispute
you
about that
and the lyrics were good
everybody was [ __ ] everybody was just
banging on all cylinders and that
guitarist sounded really good but that
guitarist was a studio style guitarist
that's who you wanted in the studio
that's not the kind of guy you wanted to
tour
with if you were motorhead
you know what i mean well those are two
different things
um because a lot of times if you have
like a studio you had like session music
sending me the name that would work
there you know
okay granthar's hammer says
would normies ever get past their goth
phobias after they got to know you
um
that's kind of hard to say because
anybody
i don't know we've had like
anybody that's because we have like some
friends that are normal looking
yeah um i mean they're weirdos like you
know in their minds yeah we have friends
that look like supermodels but we have
friends that are like normal looking
nobody would know would know they were
weirdos but us
um because on the outside they look
normal
um so i kind of feel like there's kind
of a disconnect between
people that look normal on the outside
yeah but
are cool but cool people all are all
kind of alike
real cool people they don't really care
about
that's what i mean because we have a lot
of experience with people that are
normal looking yeah that
will come up to you you're just like at
the bar like drinking or whatever like
minding your own business
and then like you have these people come
up and then they
i kind of feel like they want you to i
don't know what they want they want you
to like validate their coolness or they
want you to like can we take a picture
with you can we like hang out with you
and then like you don't really want to
do that because you don't know them and
they're like really pushy
and then
but they won't go away though all right
you know what i mean all right couple
people are asking me about mega death i
don't know if jenny knows who megadeth
is i know who megadeth are jesus christ
what do you think i do you think i live
under a rock or what who's the lead
singer at mega death i don't know what
his name is i can't remember what his
name is all right they're asking you if
you like that mega death they're all
right yeah
all right yeah dave mustaine and mega
death and everything they were good um
that that one piece sells album i bought
that one and i bought the other one it
was the one that had hangar 18 in it
what was the name it had hangry 18 had
punishment do had a bunch of good songs
on i thought that those were two the two
of his best albums
um
what was the name of that [ __ ] rust
in peace that was the name of that
[ __ ] album oh i remember yeah
dave mustaine was davis oh that's right
that's that dude dave mustaine was alex
jones before there was an alex jones he
was big into [ __ ]
world government that's unfortunate
aliens
oh she's listening that's unfortunate
[Laughter]
listen to her
[ __ ] he was big into like
government [ __ ] world government
[ __ ] uh alien
alien conspiracies just like so he was a
crazy person that's what you're saying
he's a crazy person i'm just thinking
about he was also in the comic books and
[ __ ] you know a little crazy person
i'm gonna create we tell mom they might
have an alien spacecraft probably not
but
sure okay but he was just talking he was
just talking about he was talking about
roswell you know singing songs about
roswell
we might be doing a show about that in a
couple weeks we'll see yes
it was in the poll
right
but um
no they were
you know dave was cool
they kicked him out of they kicked him
out of [ __ ] uh metallica though you
know he had he had a cocaine problem
evidently that he had a tight band
though
um i haven't heard anything he's done
recently
there was a lot of bands from that era
that were [ __ ] great that were
forgotten like i was i really liked one
of them that [ __ ] came and went kind
of quickly
well it came it did a couple of albums
and then i and i was like yeah [ __ ] them
and i thought it was it was a band
called queens reich
they had a little demo tape that they
came out they got like kind of massive
they did like silent lucidity i remember
that [ __ ] yeah that was a good song they
started to go really [ __ ] pop and
yeah they went like bon jovi style [ __ ]
and i was like what the [ __ ]
they had a first demo album it was
called queen of the reich it was pretty
good
yeah and then they came out with an
album called the warning which that
album right there just the warning album
i think is one of the best albums ever
made
and it was kind of like a concept album
taking place in the future kind of like
dune
where a [ __ ] totalitarian
government's taking over the earth it's
enslaved the nations of the earth using
a.i and mind control and dudes were
rising up to fight it and fighting
against [ __ ] fortresses of blackened
steel with laser beams and [ __ ] and it
sounds [ __ ] hokey as [ __ ]
but it was the the lyrics were very
artistic you know what i mean they
weren't doing it they weren't doing that
album um [ __ ] anvil style you know
what i mean you had to interpret what
the hell is going on it's almost kind of
like you're listening to an album that's
like singing about and it's singing
about it like it kind of happened in the
past
and it was a very good album i liked
that album and then after that they came
out with another one called um
rage for order that was a little poppier
but it had some good songs on there like
like i only see an infrared that was a
good one
um
it started to get kind of prog rocky in
that album though i was like what the
hell is this guy
but [ __ ] i think a guy's name is jeff
tate if i remember the the lead singer
and he could that [ __ ] could
sing it was a good thing yeah he could
[ __ ] sing it was kind of like iron
maiden but but more polished
um he's kind of like a bruce dickinson
type
vocal vocalist style
it's just it was just a good bad and
then after that they came out with some
with an album i think it was a double
album concept album called operation
mind crime i think it was a double album
it might not have been yeah geriatric
punk just said that yeah yeah same time
now i had a friend who was just [ __ ]
he loved that album but i just didn't
like it man i couldn't get into
operation mind crime
and i stopped listening after that one
but there are some queens right fans
that say that that is their best album i
mean i just didn't i just didn't the
thing i never liked about metal like not
metal like because i like old metal but
it's like the thing i never liked about
metal it just seems all
a little bit like too on the nose yeah
some of it was you know what i'm saying
right that's why i was saying like i
really liked the warning album because
you could kind of understand what they
were talking about but
it wasn't on the nose you had to use
your imagination that one
it's not you could not really rely on a
single band for the long term
you knew they were gonna [ __ ] up it was
gonna be
like popcorn there's certain albums of
greatness popping yeah it's just people
they're just people um
if if i was talking about over a long
term in terms of greatness in metal it
would have been judas priest
they had some bad albums uh
well no no i don't want to say that they
had some albums that weren't as good as
other of other judas priest albums some
of their songs are kind of like oh come
on man you know
but in general
judas priest delivered in general
black sabbath delivered
i'm not going to argue in general
in general ozzy osbourne delivered
although some of his [ __ ] was really
poppy man come on it was yeah um
good iron maiden albums delivered
good
good metallica albums delivered
and they were talking about venom venom
delivered that you knew what you were
getting into when you listened to venom
yeah they were a good joke band like you
said the venom was just like this
[ __ ] over-the-top satanic kind of
epic [ __ ]
and i kind of feel like they were in on
the joke of course they were that was
all theater it was like watching a
horror movie that's the see that's the
difference between them and anvil
because i feel like and particularly
from watching the anvil documentary
i feel like those dudes weren't entirely
in on the joke
which
the thing like i said it's too on the
nose and you can't if unless you're
being ironic
like no one is going to like listen to
that seriously yeah the thing with venom
is that venom didn't waste time
trying to
construct lyrics that totally made sense
it was emotional
you know what i mean evil in league with
satan and it doesn't mean anything you
know really they didn't try to all this
high-minded [ __ ] where it was on the
nose on the nose like they didn't care
it was just like it was just [ __ ]
rock and roll
basically with a bunch of [ __ ] scare
satan and satan smiles
and then the blood drips
like that was like this is just whatever
you know i mean that was a lot more
effective in the 80s when people
actually believed in satan i don't
really know like anyone
other than weirdos like warhead unleash
the lightning lord warhead they're
[ __ ] mixing nuclear warfare and
devils and demons and whatever it was
just awesomeness you know i mean and
it was kind of like gwar
but you were which like i said but the
thing about gwar though is that i knew
that was a joke one they were totally
they knew it was a joke yeah yeah we're
just gonna wear costumes and have
ridiculous names and we're gonna spray
blood and like throw separate heads at
people at the show and i've been too
many guar shows so i know so you know it
it's kind of like that kind of whole
thing i kind of feel like
i liked gwar and that kind of [ __ ]
because they were playing essentia and
the jenna torturers because they were
playing essentially the same kind of
music
but they were
ironic about it i guess they they knew
it was a joke you know what i'm saying
now comes in and says the thing about
venom is that they could not play they
could play enough
they were putting on a show yeah i'm not
gonna [ __ ] on because like a lot of punk
bands couldn't yeah yeah um and i like a
lot of that so i'm not going to show all
right brad said you guys consider porter
said goth or trip hop both well honestly
yeah i love porta's head both you got to
say i liked that it's that bad i really
like porter said
um everything i've heard of them like
i'm not a super fan or anything but it's
like everything i've heard of theirs was
like it was good yeah it had a goth vibe
to it yeah and a lot of guys were really
really like that if you played that in a
club nowadays like a lot of people will
be into it i don't even like you know
we're not really super worried about it
yeah uh camp guy brings up the cocktail
twins that's another band goths liked it
that i [ __ ] love i love the cocktail
twins yeah honestly we were [ __ ] man we
were just at uh mannequins on saturday
yeah and he played a cocktail twin song
i was super excited about it that's what
[ __ ] to
cocktail twins a lot oh yeah that was
what you [ __ ] up that and mazzy star
you were [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of each
other the badly started yeah and a
canopy bed [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah that was like that was the sex that
was that was 90s sex [ __ ] music
well cocktail twins i feel like that was
more like 80s [ __ ] music well yeah but
in the 90s though but yeah but it went
on into the 90s sure
um honestly the cocktail twins are like
super super good
i
i really really like them
uh somebody said about
lollapalooza i went to the first
lollapalooza
in
1991
1991
yeah in atlanta
it was
rollins band
butthole surfers
susie and the banshees
jane's addiction
nine inch nails
living color
the [ __ ] else was there
those are the ones i remember but it's
like it was atlanta
and it was daytime
and
man i would like i wanted to go early
because i wanted to see the rollins
being the butthole surfers who were like
the first two bands that were playing
but i was going with my best friend at
the time and uh you know we just
graduated high school like a year before
and we were going with her boyfriend
and we were staying at her boyfriend's
roommate's apartment which was the
filthy uh [ __ ] pit
and
so no one got their [ __ ] together in
time to like get to the show and i was
really irritated about it so i'm like
you guys can't even like get up and like
shower and like get your [ __ ] together
like to go to this okay fine
um
because i don't i don't have any
patience for people that can't get their
[ __ ] together like in time to go do
something i just really don't so it's
like you can't like oh i said oh i gotta
sleep oh now i gotta do this and it's
like [ __ ] off just like
yeah let's go
so i missed the first two bands i was
super super pissed
but so we finally finally
got there
and so we saw susie we saw jane's
addiction we saw nine inch nails that
was like one of 50 million times i saw
night of jails like not even on purpose
i think i only saw nightingales on
purpose one time
like i i saw them and uh who opened for
them manifesto
like i i went to that show like on
purpose but every other time i saw them
they opened for someone else like i saw
them opening for peter murphy i saw them
opening up like i saw them lollapalooza
i saw them like opening for a bunch of
other bands so it's like it's just funny
how i
[ __ ] saw them accidentally so many
times but and i like managed nails i'm
not [ __ ] on them but like so
the first lollapalooza
it was really good i just wish
that it hadn't been
mostly the daytime
and mostly like 100 [ __ ] degrees we
had to like keep putting sunscreen on it
was atlanta i mean
not as bad as florida but almost
and so it was kind of like that so like
seeing susan the banshees
awesome
seeing them like
in the middle of the day and like 90
degrees
doesn't really like it's not real
conducive like to the atmosphere just
saying
but
you know what are you going to do
and the [ __ ] oh he's taking his clothes
off
the shitty thing was that man is it
getting hot yeah okay
in
1994 1995
uh there was a lollapalooza and it was
not too long after nick cave's uh let
love in had come out so that came out in
94 so this must have been lollapalooza
94.95
so nick cave was on lollapalooza l7 were
also on lola blues and i was a big fan
of l7
so
the lollapalooza that year was going to
be in deland at the deland fairground
which i lived in daytona at the time
that was like 20 minutes away i was
super jacked so i had tickets i was like
oh my god i'm gonna see nick cave this
would be [ __ ] awesome
like mid 90s i was all about it
and then like i go to sleep i'm so
excited and then like the morning i get
up it's been storming all night long
and then my cousin who was two years old
and me she calls me and she's like your
[ __ ] got canceled because the fairground
in deland which was like the central
florida fairgrounds it flooded out
because of the of those storms last
night so it's like the store the stage
collapsed so none of the bands are gonna
play so they just like canceled it and i
was like so [ __ ] bummed so to this
day
i have never seen nick cave live because
i had tickets to see him back then
after let loving come out and the
[ __ ] storm the [ __ ] storm ruined
everything
[ __ ] florida
[ __ ] florida
it was so close i was so excited
and it just it ruined it and i'm still
bitter about it it's gonna be all right
jenny to this day do you realize it is
like almost time for us to [ __ ] end
this uh stream no it's not we're having
a good time
i want to eat
do you yeah eventually
well eventually that one's russia
anything
all right let's see we've been on for
three hours
three hours yeah 26 minutes
yeah i don't want to do a four-hour show
what are your thoughts on the curiouses
brad man again
we've been talking about the cure no we
haven't i'll be talking on other shows
the cure was great
they're really good i really like the
cure although honestly i didn't buy
anything of theirs after disintegration
because i graduated from high school in
1990
i bought disintegration and i liked it
but then after that i kind of felt like
well
i didn't i wasn't done with the cure but
i was just kind of like okay well
i bought it all the way until violet
moves swings yeah like i liked some
other songs like after that
but
they were consistently good they are
like all their [ __ ] is yeah that was
that was one of the bands that was
consistently it was consistent
everything that everything they put out
is always like worth listening to they
didn't they didn't put out anything bad
and there was a lot of stuff that they
didn't put out that was good that ended
up like escaping on
like uh
bootlegs
there's a lot of bootleg stuff that got
released they're like oh yeah that's
good too
i had a friend who collected bootleg or
he collected all cure albums
and some of them were bootleg this is
back in the 90s
[ __ ] that i'd never even heard of
you know i mean they have stuff massive
back catalog yeah
because i
i stopped buying stuff of theirs in 1990
and i'm always like surprised because
like i said i have my like my radio
station and it like throws up the cure
like pretty often and i'm just kind of
like i don't even know this song okay
all right
like you know it's the cure because it
sounds like them
brad says i graduated in 2002. oh my god
you're a baby and it reminds me of high
school even though it was an 80s band
yeah i mean
i graduated like i said i graduated in
1990 that was my that was my senior year
and that was the year disintegration
came out and i remember we all like all
the weirdos at school like had that
and i liked it but
and like i like it honestly i like it
better now
than i did back then
it aged really
well and i kind of feel like a lot of
bands nowadays like a starry night um
you know were really influenced by that
so i think i appreciate it more now than
i did at the time but i still have to
say that as far as the cure goes
i'm like way more into
their
1977 to 1988
era
you know what i'm saying
you're not gonna comment of that no
yeah that's about right i'm just saying
like i like all their old punk rock [ __ ]
you know
you know uh and it was like
it was all yeah like i you know 17
seconds all that sort of pornography
faith all that [ __ ] was good i liked the
top even kissed me kissed me kissed me
which was what 87 that's probably one of
the best albums of all times yeah that's
a great album too like it's a very
diverse pop and psychedelic yeah
together with like like goth
and that that was like a great album
granters if you want to hear a [ __ ]
badass
goth album get the cure kiss me kiss me
kiss me get that one we'll actually have
to get it you listen to it on uh youtube
fantastic album
now
kind of like a harder
goth would probably be pornography that
was a really good album too man that
album [ __ ] dragon to me that album
and sisters of mercy first and last
always are kind of like the
quintessential like goth rock
albums because as much as people like
say like go bat house and stuff like
that which i love bauhaus
um i like bauhaus even more than the
than the cure but
bauhaus always had their own thing going
on i kind of feel like bauhaus were kind
of like all over the place they had like
more of a dark glam
kind of [ __ ]
not so much goth rock
[ __ ] that became goth rock later on
like in the 90s you know you had [ __ ]
bands like um rosetta stone and stuff
like that
the bands they were copying
was
80s era cure yeah and early sisters of
mercy that's who they were cops with a
little bit of a little bit of joy
division at it that too
so yeah so i kind of feel like people
that got into gotham the 90s
you know hearkening back to that that
was harkening back to right the like the
gothic rock kind of thing because when
that [ __ ] was coming out i mean that
sisters of mercy was out when i was in
high school
but there was no such thing as goth then
it had not been codified yet
even had bauhaus back then we didn't
have a word for it though it was just
some kind of weird
art band music
it had not become a subculture yet
it wasn't it wasn't really until the
[ __ ] very early 90s
that you could call it goth
now grandparents knows what i'm talking
about
88
in that 88 89 era i was living in
detroit and there was a bit there was a
club there
called called um
city club no one's called city club
what was that [ __ ] called
we had san andreas hall yeah city club
another and then you had nothing called
the shelter
and they were playing [ __ ] weird ass
music one of them was [ __ ] front 242.
the other one was skinny puppy which was
a kind of a local band but they were
from across the
they were from across well they're from
ontario yeah they're from across the
border in in in canada
and
everything was kind of coalescen into
what
eventually became goth at least in
america and i watched that [ __ ]
happening in detroit and it was a weird
time
um
it had
you saw girls that looked kind of like
punk rockers
i didn't i didn't know what to call it
they looked like girls that looked like
had kind of like punk rock haircuts
makeup
fish nets i thought that [ __ ] was sexy
as [ __ ]
and then just weird pointy boots i know
i recognize them now as they were pixie
boots
um
they were wearing underwear
their underwear were on the outside
of the f of of the fishermen remember
the leotards remember those
and um
big black susie haircuts and big black
susie eye makeup and i didn't know
really what to make with it i just
thought it was like punk rock um
granters would know what i was talking
about they were kind of like
um
they were the same kind of girl that you
would see um
little uh gene petrowski and uh her
friend uh
the little punk rock girls little
redhead and then the [ __ ] girl the
mohawk i forgot what her name was
he would remember who it was
it was
that kind of chick and they were all
hanging out downtown
and then i saw some dudes they were just
cool as [ __ ] i was like who [ __ ] i
didn't know who i was looking at but
that was kevin key and david ogfy from
[ __ ] skinny puppy yeah hanging out in
there
you know and they were much cooler than
me i wasn't going to go [ __ ] talk to
those people it took
it took um
a couple of years for it to all coalesce
into what i would call it be the ghost
scene
but then i had to move away and then a
couple months later i was in the army
and while i was in the army that's
really when it kind of became a thing so
i had to wait a couple years i got out
of the army and was able to go to main
race in boston and that's really kind of
where
the scene had been fully [ __ ] formed
you knew how you were supposed to look
and had changed
because
it's now it it was now very 1700s
looking kind of anne rice kind of
interview the vampire type mixed with
fetish wear
you know
man i remember reading in rice when i
was like in the early 80s
and that [ __ ] blew my [ __ ] mind yeah
that between like reading and race and
reading clive barker
that like blew my [ __ ] mind in the
early 80s because i was a kid you know
what i mean but it's like it's weird
because like people nowadays i don't
think if you didn't grow up in that time
it was something that
nobody really knew like i said nobody
really knew what goth was i didn't know
what goth was that wasn't really a goth
thing until the 90s yeah and honestly i
had been into the [ __ ] since the 90s i
had been into the [ __ ] since like the
early 80s when i was a kid
because i was kind of like i like all
this creepy [ __ ] i like this creepy
music that i was like hearing from
various sources but i didn't have like a
name for it i didn't have like
there was no there was nothing to like
grasp onto i didn't know anybody else
that was into that kind of [ __ ] it had
not crystallized into right and it's
like so i kind of feel like for a lot of
the 80s i was kind of lucky in the sense
that like you know junior high was like
sucky because everyone just thought i
was satanist because no one knew what
goth was there was no like there was no
framework
um when i was in high school it was
slightly better because i did like i me
i met some people that were like some
people were like into punk or they were
into like ska or something like that we
all kind of like hung out together and
it's kind of like we kind of have
had a little scene going
but you know my brother was in a punk
band he was a little bit younger than me
so there was like a little bit of like a
punk rock thing going on
so we hung out with like
punks
but
there wasn't really like a coalesced
i feel like there wasn't really a
coalesce goth scene until the 90s at
least in florida
i mean for mike it was the same thing in
detroit yeah yeah um
you know where i grew up there was like
nothing it was a you know i grew up in
daytona beach it's like very rednecky
so
you know i knew i knew some people but
nobody was like uh you know i had some
friends that were like most of the same
[ __ ] as me they liked bauhaus and
cocktail twins and stuff that's what
they look like until i know that's what
i look like when i was with you until
the night this is what the one that
ended up as goths looked like this
yeah well that's until the very early
night you didn't have
i
we didn't have hot topic yeah until i
was like old right
i shopped at the i me and my little
brother who was four years younger we
shopped at the arm we went to the army
navy store yeah and thrift stores
we would buy like old lady like i'd buy
like old lady like black lace dresses
we'd go to the army navy store and buy
like old jump boots
um that's just what you wore or you had
to make your own [ __ ] yeah or you had to
like mail order stuff yeah grandpa's
going that was a trenton goth yeah but
the thing is we didn't have a word for
it
that's what i mean there wasn't really
any kind of like and like if you went
out looking like that people would
didn't like know what to make of it yeah
and that that girl that i just showed
you is a real girl that me and granters
knew
and um
her name was jean
and there was only like about four or
five other ones at the school and that
was about 86
86 or 87
and that's what it looked like it wasn't
until the very early 90s it had kind of
crystallized
into into what i kind of feel like in
the 90s like the mid like the early to
mid 90s i feel like goth kind of went
mainstream
you kind of had it come up like tim
burton got famous like you had all the
kind of [ __ ] like later on you had like
underworld you had all that kind of
stuff so it's like people had a context
or a framework
they knew where you were coming from
right
prior to that
uh people didn't really know
like what your deal was and if they
don't know what your deal is then
they're gonna like [ __ ] with you about
it
so
there was that whole issue too like i'm
gonna pull out your high school pictures
you probably don't have any high school
pictures left i do somewhere yeah um i
still have like my natural hair color
when i was in high school my natural
hair color in case you don't guys don't
know is
bright copper red
i'm yes i'm a ginger i have no soul i
know
um when i was in high school my hair was
kind of like this but it was only like
it was half shaped i this half was
shaved
and then this half was like poofy
but it was all um
like copper red so i had like copper red
like on here but it was like shaved on
this side
i had two piercings i had and everything
i wore in high school
was
band t-shirts
um
a
dark green
trench coat that i bought at a thrift
store for three dollars yeah and
boots that i bought at the army navy
store
that's what i wore in high school this
is why everybody made fun of me i bought
i had my like cool cure shirts and my
mighty lemon drop shirts i had an alien
sex bean shirt in the south that
wouldn't have flown up next uh yeah tell
me about it
in michigan nobody would have noticed
but down here that's fine
down here it was uh a little bit
different yeah a little bit hot here you
know
it's hot they had no idea what you were
doing
yeah that's what i mean nobody honestly
i grew up like you're not listening to
molly hatchet
[Laughter]
daytona beach you guys
daytona beach what's up pokey i grew up
in daytona beach i was born there i grew
up there most of my life
and
it's it's better now but it's like at
the time it was very rednecky
um the main radio stations in town
because that was kind of like a thing
back then we're a country station
and
an old like you know a southern rock
station they played like leonard skinner
the eagles that kind of stuff those are
like the two main radio stations
you didn't have anything else
every now and then when i was a kid
you could get the college station from
gainesville
you know if you kind of [ __ ] with your
[ __ ] like if the weather conditions were
right and they would maybe play like rem
or something which would be cool like
back in the 80s
but that was about it and you had mtv
that was pretty much it
yeah mtv was like the savior yeah gotta
say that played all like the new wave
[ __ ] stop it pokey don't bite that
yeah bust out your high school picks
i'll have to like you know what
if you like no
if you remind me i'll scan i gotta find
it but i'll like i'll find it
i had um
i had half my head shaved in high school
but my hair was still its natural color
which was bright red but i still had
half the head shaved
but i had to like for the high school
pictures high school pictures you either
had to wear like that [ __ ]
black [ __ ] they made you wear or i was
wearing my chorus dress
which you know yeah i might have some
geriatric punk says marilyn manson
what i don't know what about maryland
um we were [ __ ] grown in long island
out of high school yeah i well marilyn
manson
yeah [ __ ] maryland we yeah we have like
conflicting feelings about marilyn
manson like he's from here his name is
brian warner he's a friend of a friend
of ours yeah he yeah
um he's from this area not originally
but he did like live here for a long
time
so
i kind of blame maryland i know it's not
his fault
but i kind of blame marilyn manson
for
mainstreaming
what used to be
kind of a cool
[ __ ]
you know it
early 2000s late 90s early 2000s you go
to a goth club you're waiting online
waiting to go in
some
[Music]
basic [ __ ]
some karen behind you in today's
parlance is behind you
slumming
oh we're gonna do some weird [ __ ] we're
gonna like hang out with these weird
people
so they're behind you in line
and all of a sudden they just shout at
you marilyn manson which i've had happen
more than one more than one time they
would just call you marilyn manson
marilyn manson david driving by marilyn
manson i [ __ ] you
i don't even like marilyn manson like
why are you yelling at it marilyn manson
was pop music
it was pop it was pop rock i mean it was
it was [ __ ] top 20.
if i remember correctly he hit the top
20. it wasn't
it was kind of revolutionary when it hit
but it wasn't revolutionary for us it
was it was revolutionary for y'all and
really that's what i mean that's what
like made me mad about it it's like
honestly
i'm walking through the mall
like what like in the late 80s like 89
90. and somebody says to me lydia
from beetlejuice yeah and at that point
i was kind of like [ __ ]
i've been dressing like this since 1984.
yeah um i know the movie just came out
for you and it's like that because when
beetlejuice came out i was like super
excited because i'm like oh my god a
real goth girl like in a movie and it's
like i've never seen that before
but
everybody else saw that [ __ ] too and so
like now now you can't like walk down
the street and everybody thinks you're
like impersonating her i'm like no i'm
just like i've been dressed like that
phenomenal that have been for years
before that and it's like now you guys
are just noticing it so now everybody's
gonna call me that and it's like when
the matrix came out i had the same
problem it was like hey matrix hey neo
hey you know yeah they do that goth was
retroactive that that is christ that
word goth
came from rolling stones
in the late 80s stop it pokey it was
when the rolling stones described peter
murphy
as somebody like a gothic pixie
i kind of feel well gothic even goes
back further like joy division we're
called gothic susan the banshees were
called gothic the doors were called
gothic back in like the late 60s it
really stuck when
rolling stones described
described peter murphy as a gothic pixie
victor said at my school they used to
yell at columbine yeah we got that too
and once i was out of school by then
thankfully once rolling stone co called
him a gothic pixie things that looked
like that started to be called goth
and then retroactively things that were
happening in the early 80s and even the
late 70s even the 60s like the doors
some people started to say that's kind
of gothic
so it was retroactive it was put
retroactively on things
but
even in the early 90s it was not cool to
be called goth
we were at the cool we were at the uh
man rape if people said are you god they
would [ __ ] deny it they say no
well no one wanted to be associated with
that term after it became um you're
right that was something that it becomes
so sully right at that stage they would
deny being goth
you know i think andrew eldritch denied
being goth he stole those as far as i
know yeah yeah
so um
it was just a cultural phenomenon that
was placed on things really but you know
you might as well embrace it
yeah yeah that's what it is
i'm not bothered by it nowadays but
it pissed me off at the time because
like i said i don't really appreciate
being called like
you know as much as i love lydia from
beetlejuice it's like i don't
appreciate being called that like in
1988 when i've been dressing like that
for four years like several years before
the movie came out
just because now i'm represented in a
movie yeah there's a bunch of [ __ ]
that's got off that was never [ __ ]
called goth but i would say it like you
know
bands like [ __ ] the legendary pink
dots
um
stuff like the old neofolk bands like
like current 93 and death in june
they're not called goth but
gothic people listen to that and i i'd
put it in there be like gothic folk you
know
it's just
over ha [ __ ] it i don't care to explain
it anymore it just
and there was some stuff that was
[ __ ] just openly got that kind of
sucked too you know what i mean
[Laughter]
so well like it's that whole tryhard
issue like we're talking about like the
manly man thing right if you have to
like go so over the top then it's it
starts to suck because to me
i mean the whole thing about like the re
i think the reason that all that stuff
pissed me off so much and still does
even though i'm old now was that
i grew up in a time where there was no
um that wasn't a thing that was an
identity that you could like latch onto
there was no hot topic there was no
that wasn't like a codified
scene
so
i grew up
being a girl and i was just kind of like
oh i really like horror [ __ ] i really
like morticia i really like like all
that kind of witchy stuff but i didn't
really have a i didn't know anybody else
it wasn't that kind of [ __ ] lily michael
black tape for a blue girl yeah they
were goth oh my god i have like i have a
couple i have a couple of years left
back there too right i have like a stack
of cds back there and you can't see them
right but uh yeah i have that as yeah
and that's what he's talking about
looking at this is those weren't goth
kids was a vampire kids yeah that was
another thing that's a whole other thing
vampires are are a gothic concept
but goths aren't vampires i guess that's
the best way to put at it put it there
was
some goths were kind of vampiric
but that's not what goth was that was
just like a little thing that was like a
subculture of it you know well i feel
like there's kind of like a whole
i mean and the reason that the
subculture has persuasions i'm still
silly talking about this [ __ ] because no
in fact so far here on a management well
the reason that the subculture has
persisted for this long yeah is because
it's a mindset it's not really i mean
you're born like i said i didn't even
like have a word for it i didn't like i
didn't know anybody else that was into
the [ __ ] i was just kind of like i
really really like creepy [ __ ] i like
ghost stories i like the addams family i
like that and when i heard
early goth music like in the late 70s
early 80s i'm like yeah i like that
that's
that's my thing right there and like but
i didn't know that there was other
people that were in yeah lily said
anything on project records was ethereal
or goth yes it was and the ethereal was
goth
yeah i liked it i liked a lot of that
they had a lot of good ethereal stuff uh
man you remember uh
oh [ __ ] the shroud the shroud was a good
i [ __ ] loved the shroud shot up with
that yeah i still like the crowd yeah i
have a couple of their cds back there
also
it was kind of like the gothic version
of [ __ ]
led zeppelin [ __ ] where the wind
blows this [ __ ] definitely stairway
to heaven that's very close to it i
don't know i feel like day and night is
more like the the stairway to heaven
your day and i am night never the two
shall meet you know it's that kind of
holy [ __ ]
well she yeah lily says i was born goth
like yeah i kind of feel like i was like
i didn't even know there wasn't a word
for it
but
i don't know ever since i was a kid i
was just i like creepy [ __ ] i like
creepy [ __ ] and i didn't know that there
was other people that liked it i thought
it was i thought it was just me and i
was a weirdo
but
you know i think it's legally as
impressed i know the shroud yeah yeah
yeah she goes yes the shroud oh my god i
[ __ ] love the shroud i have like a
dark moon night and i might have another
one back there too but there's like a
big stack of cd that's another music you
could [ __ ] too
oh yeah
it'd be bad oh big time yeah i really
like this round
yeah they're i'm sure there's no
feelings to hold me down
oh where the wind blows yeah you guys
want to hear a good gothic song [ __ ]
go just look up the shroud where the
wind blows that's a [ __ ] good song
man that whole album was good i really
like that album
i liked all that [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm
honestly like i said i'm more like an
80s death rock kind of person
but some of that 90 [ __ ] was good too
but i kind of like that like a more
ethereal goth kind of [ __ ] i like you
know i'm not [ __ ] i like a rosetta
stone i like uh who else get raised in
black they were all right
um who else came out in the 90s
switchless symphony is awesome
i don't know and and then also i really
liked was this 90s or 2000s i really
liked the
uh
what do they call it the [ __ ] um
that revival they had that was like all
kind of like 20s kind of [ __ ]
oh you're talking about um
what's that word
they did they were doing two oh rasputin
very cool too stuff like that although
that's like dresden dolls were doing
dresden i [ __ ] love the driving dog
um all that kind of stuff that was like
a cabaret like the cabaret goth i love
that kind of [ __ ] because i feel like
there was like a big resurgence in that
so i really like that
but
i don't know man
there's a lot of good [ __ ] i like a lot
i like a lot of chicken
only about the poncho well um [ __ ] we've
been going for near um four hours
lately likes raspatina adora remember
adora this is a long time ago yeah yeah
yeah fuzz box oh my god i remember them
yeah we've got a fuzz box and we're
going to use it yeah i think i had that
album on vinyl
i think it's gone now but specimen
man it's best well specimen roll yeah i
[ __ ] lost both i love it like i said
i love all that bat cave [ __ ] um
yeah amanda palmer hated being called
the goth bantu yeah i mean i don't know
i do
amanda palmer's solo stuff which i like
some of her solo stuff too but
i wouldn't call it goth but it's still
good though dresden dolls was kind of
more
they were like a cabaret yeah kind of
[ __ ] but it's goth adjacent my ex-wife
i'll allow it my ex-wife had this cd
that was a
goth bands nothing but goth pants doing
cover songs from dead can dance man it
was [ __ ] great maybe you guys might
remember [ __ ] what the name of that i
had the goth bands covering
david bowie yeah and i also had the goth
bands covering bauhaus
this was guys i have it back there goth
bands covering dead can dance that was
that was around
1996 or seven it was [ __ ] great album
honestly i just can't find it i forgot
what speaking of which
when bauhaus toured
like with their you know re surgeons or
whatever
in the late 90s
they covered
dead condance's severance and it was
beautiful yeah beautiful
it wasn't on that album david jim says
this is a good show yo
i hope that you're liking it um
hoping for more bs scenarios of x versus
x i don't know what you talk about
um based on three six every time okay
well look jen we've been [ __ ]
streaming lily says love the golf talk
we got it we got to get off of here
we've been on here for four hours and i
gotta make it something to eat
what are you gonna make
uh tacos or meatloaf one or two they got
both
we had tacos earlier yeah i could have
another one it doesn't matter to me he
wants meatloaf you can finish the
meatloaf off
meatloaf and potatoes baked potato
that sounds good actually okay all right
we'll do that all right let's go ahead
and shut it down then
we've been on for about four hours all
right so we're coming back friday night
yes we're gonna be talking about
charles
whitman
okay texas tower yeah yeah that's a good
case i know all about that we saw
the movie so it's perfectly russell kurt
russell
it's in the crystal sphere yeah yeah we
just watched that not too long ago yeah
i also read about the case though
[ __ ] you know we're going to be
talking about that dude uh that was what
won in the patreon poll this week okay
we'll do that we'll be talking about
that on friday night waving but yeah so
it's been a fun show you guys
david chewin says i want meatloaf
we have some left over tom made some the
other day yeah but uh made two big ones
eight them [ __ ] up all protein
yeah it's all meat it's all protein
pretty much there's bread crumbs in it
but whatever meat on meat on meat you
kind of like that thing from sliver
that's what i just said meat meat it's
not sliver it's uh
it's literally
it's late at night it's wednesday night
all right so we will be back on friday
evening talking about charles whitman
i'm sure that's gonna be like a bummer
but okay
uh so yeah we'll see you guys later
thank you very much for dropping by
thanks for super chats thanks for
hanging out with us we will see you guys
on friday evening
goodbye